genauso ist es Florian Bauer guten
Morgen hier aus dem Deutschen Bundestag
von uns also das wird ein Winter der Not
so hat es Vizekanzler Robert Habeck
dieser Tage in einem Interview nochmal
zu Protokoll gegeben darauf müssen wir
uns einstellen die Bundesregierung
versucht dagegen anzuarbeiten mit vielen
Milliarden mit Bremsen und durchaus auch
mit Deckeln das ist das Rezept die Frage
ist wie gut wirkt das gegen die Preise
in der Krise Antworten darauf jetzt von
meinen beiden Gästen ich darf ganz
herzlich begrüßen die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Bündnis grünen
hier im Bundestag Julia Verlinden die
gleichzeitig auch Mitglied der
Expertenkommission für Energie und Wärme
gewesen ist und ich freue mich dass da
als Andreas Jung er ist Sprecher für
Klima und Energiepolitik der
Unionsfraktion und stellvertretender
Parteivorsitzender der CDU hoffe
anfangen die Strom und die
gaspreisbremse heute in der ersten
Lesung es sind auch noch viele andere
Dinge die auf der Tagesordnung sind das
eine Brandmauer gegen
hohe Preissteigerung das sagt der
Wirtschaftsminister mal abgesehen davon
dass das Bild sehr explosiv ist wenn ich
an Feuer und an Gas denke aber das
lassen wir dahin gestellt welche
Garantie dass das jetzt klappt mit dem
was sie angehen also wir haben einen
klaren Zeitplan so dass diese Gas und
strompreisbremsen auch im nächsten Jahr
in Kraft treten und alle Menschen dann
auch sich darauf verlassen können dass
sie an der Stelle ja einen Deckel
bekommen das heißt dass es nicht weiter
steigen wird die Energiepreise im
Bereich Strom Gas und auch Fernwärme und
das ist wichtig um hier auch Sicherheit
zu geben wir haben mit hohen
Energiepreisen auf dem Weltmarkt zu tun
und deswegen ist es richtig hier jetzt
entsprechend gegenzusteuern über
mögliche Mitnahmeeffekte die jetzt schon
im Raum stehen können weil dann später
gleich noch reden wenn wir über die
strompreisbremse sprechen Herr Jung es
gibt von von ihrer Seite ganz konkret
von ihrem Partei und
Fraktionsvorsitzenden gab es eine
relativ heftige Kritik am Wochenende
kurz atme und mit ganz heißer Nadel
gestrickt war so etwa die Formulierung
ist das nur eine Kritik am Timing oder
gibt es sozusagen ein strukturelles
Problem dass sie sehen ist offenkundig
mit heißer Nagel gestrickt weil mir erst
im September begonnen hat wir wussten ja
seit Frühjahr spätestens im Sommer es
gibt eine Preisexplosion dann hat aber
Olaf Scholz erstmal die gasumlage
vorgeschlagen dadurch wurde der Sommer
vertan dann wurde die Kommission
eingesetzt der ist in fast unzumuntern
eurer Zeitdruck gemacht worden das ist
der Blick zurück aber der hat
Auswirkungen heute was dazu führt dass
diese Bremsen die wir brauchen erst im
März kommen und deshalb hat die
Regierung mehrere Notlösungen drum
rumgestickt dadurch wird es sehr
kompliziert und es droht in der
Umsetzung dass viele Fragen aufgeworfen
werden und dieses Vertrauen dass wir
brauchen eben nicht geschaffen wird das
ist der eine Punkt der zweite Punkt da
wird jetzt gemacht etwas bei Strom und
beim Gas es wird aber nichts gemacht bei
den Menschen und Betrieben die mit Öl
und Pellets heizen die sollen Härtefälle
werden das sind aber keine Härtefälle
das sind ganz viele Menschen und
Betriebe aus der Mitte der Gesellschaft
und deshalb sind Lücken in diesem Paket
gut dass das parlamentarische Verfahren
beginnt ja das ist der Punkt den sie
auch schon länger machen Frau verlinken
im Grunde genommen lag jetzt hier ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt drin nämlich die
Frage ist hat die Regierung hier
unnotwendigerweise Vertrauen verspielt
indem sie wirklich diese Kritik kommt
übrigens auch aus den Ländern das
Planungssicherheit fehlt für die KMU ist
also die kleinen und mittleren
Unternehmen zum Beispiel aus
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern kam ganz konkret
diese Kritik also haben sie einfach ein
bisschen zu wenig Tempo gegeben das
glaube ich nicht also wir sind seit dem
Februar seit diesem schrecklichen
Angriffskrieg ja dabei Entlastungen zu
organisieren das ist ja jetzt auch nicht
die erste Entlastung die auf dem Weg
gebracht wird zahlreiche Milliarden sind
schon ausgeschüttet worden sind schon
bei den Menschen angekommen bei den
Unternehmen angekommen und das ist jetzt
ein weiterer Schritt um sich auf den ja
auf das kommende Jahr vorzubereiten
heute allein ist diese Dezember
Soforthilfe in Kraft getreten das heißt
all diejenigen Menschen die heute
theoretisch ihren Abschlag für ihre
Gasrechnung hätten zahlen müssen müssen
das nicht tun die ein Dauerauftrag haben
beispielsweise konnten diesen
zurückziehen für den Dezember bzw es
wurde nicht eingezogen von den
Energieversorgung und diejenigen die
über ihre Vermieter abgerechnet werden
die bekommen das Geld entsprechend
zurück über ihre Nebenkostenabrechnung
das heißt die dezemberzahlungen für Gas
und Fernwärme hat der Staat übernommen
und das heißt diese Entlastung ist auch
heute bei den Menschen schon angekommen
wenn ich direkt einen Vertrag habe mit
meinem Versorger wenn ich einen Mieter
in einer Mietwohnung bin dann muss ich
darauf warten bis nächsten Dezember bis
der Vermieter entsprechend über den
Nebenkostenabrechnung kommt so ein
bisschen drauf an wenn bereits eine
Erhöhung stattgefunden hat dann kann ich
jetzt bereits schon meinen Abschlag
reduzieren das sind verschiedene
Rahmenbedingungen der Vermieter hatte
mich übrigens dann darüber informieren
müssen wie das jetzt ab heute aussieht
wenn ich eben in einer Mietwohnung lebe
dann schaue ich heute mal in meinem
Briefkasten ähm Frau verlinken wenn wir
beide jetzt hier rausgehen aus dem
Deutschen Bundestag mal abgesehen davon
dass relativ kalt ist gerade aktuell in
Berlin und diese harte Winter eigentlich
schon beginnt dann würden wir
wahrscheinlich ein Problem haben
jemanden zu finden der uns ad hoc
erklären kann die Funktionsweise dieses
doch recht komplizierten Konstrukt also
hat die Politik da jetzt wirklich ein
Problem auch wieder mit dem Erklären von
dem ganzen
nun wir hatten die Erwartungen zu
erfüllen dass wir sehr schnell handeln
und das ist auch gut funktioniert und
deswegen sind wir in der
Expertenkommission Gas und Wärme zu dem
Schluss gekommen dass es sinnvoll ist
über die Energieversorger zu gehen denn
die haben alle Kundendaten die haben
alle Kontoverbindungen und wenn die
Energieversorger ab nächstem Jahr
deutlich weniger einziehen weniger Geld
abbuchen bei den Menschen für Strom Gas
und Fernwärme dann ist es ein sehr
praktikables Vorgehen es ist ein
Instrument was schnell funktioniert und
was natürlich jetzt erstmal auch noch
von den Energieversorgern umgesetzt wird
aber wir haben den Vorteil dass wir im
Gesetzentwurf auch stehen haben das ist
auch rückwirkend gilt also das heißt
auch die Monate Februar und Januar
werden dann im März verrechnet heute ist
noch nichts in der Börse weil sie ist
gerade so ein bisschen den Raum gestellt
haben nicht dass jemand jetzt schaut und
enttäuscht sondern es ist noch Frist bis
März bis dann was fließt ähm sie haben
schon die Kritik gemacht das Timings
jetzt könnten wir natürlich noch mal
fragen nach dem strukturellen Punkt also
hätten Sie es denn grundsätzlich anders
gemacht abgesehen davon dass sie
schneller gemacht hätten wenn sie an
charge werden wir halten die
Konstruktion von Strom und
gaspreisbremse im Grundsatz für richtig
das ist ja auch ein Vorschlag der
zurückgeht auf die Kommission da sind
sehr viele kluge Menschen mit guten
Gedanken dabei gewesen das halten wir im
Grundsatz für richtig wir glauben aber
dass Gruppen außen vor gelassen werden
Öl und Pellets erwähnt dass die
einfachen Dinge nicht gemacht werden
warum macht man nicht das klare Signal
die Mehrwertsteuer geht runter auf alle
Energieträger auf alle auch etwa auf
Strom der der umgestellt hat von Gas auf
Strom der bleibt beim hohen
Mehrwertsteuersatz und der bei Gas hätte
niedrigen das passt doch nicht zusammen
und unsere Kritik bezieht sich vor allem
dann auch auf den Teil wo eine
Erneuerbaren Bremse vorgelegt wird mit
dem abschöpfungsmechanismus sie haben
gesagt er ist manches kompliziert da
haben wir einen gemeinsamen europäischen
Rahmen aber niemand macht so kompliziert
in Deutschland wir sind auf dem Weg zur
Europa-Meisterschaft in komplizierter
Umsetzung aber wir wollen doch Vorreiter
mit den Erneuerbaren sein die werden
aber hier abgewürgt und sie werden
schlechter behandelt als die fossilen
sie werden schlechter behandelt als die
Kernenergie und deshalb braucht es
gerade an diesem Punkt veränderungs muss
es klare Signal geben das was man mit
dem osterpaket beschleunigen wollte das
wird jetzt nicht im Winter wieder
eingerissen also da ist eine ganz
konkrete Kritik übrigens ist natürlich
der Europa mit dem Boot und wir haben
einmal schon bei Mehrwertsteuer Fragen
erlebt dass das gar nicht so einfach ist
irgendwas abzusenken was man möchte weil
Europa könnte man sofort beschließen
heute im Bundestag warum machen wir es
nicht einfach also ich glaube es ist
jetzt für die Menschen weniger relevant
an welcher Stelle die Entlastung
tatsächlich umgesetzt wird ob das an der
Mehrwertsteuer hängt oder ob wir den
Strompreis Deckeln auf einen bestimmten
Betrag die EEG-Umlage beispielsweise
haben wir im Sommer bereits abgeschafft
das war auch eine Entlastung von
mehreren Cent pro Kilowattstunde das
heißt am Ende ist kommt es darauf an wie
viel kostet die Kilowattstunde und ob
das an welcher Stelle jetzt geschraubt
wird ist glaube ich für die Menschen
weniger relevant sondern wichtig ist sie
können sich jetzt auf einen Strompreis
Verlassen der das ganze das nächste Jahr
gilt der gilt bis
bis diese Krise sozusagen auch
überwunden ist die wir aktuell haben und
deswegen ist es notwendig hier jetzt
schnell in die Umsetzung zu kommen aber
ich gebe Ihnen Recht wir müssen an der
Stelle
wie finanzieren wir die strompreisbremse
und an welcher Stelle schöpfen wir die
sogenannten zufallsgewinne von den
Energieerzeugern also von den
Stromerzeugern ab da müssen wir noch mal
genauer hinschauen dass das keine neuen
Investitionen in erneuerbare verhindert
weil das wäre natürlich die schlechteste
Botschaft und deswegen schauen wir da im
parlamentarischen Verfahren auch noch
mal ganz genau hin die Klagewelle von
der Solarbranche ist mehr oder weniger
bereits angedroht dem sehen Sie gelassen
entgegen
wie gesagt wir prüfen das jetzt im
parlamentarischen Verfahren ob da an
einer Stelle noch mal nachjustiert
werden muss aber wie gesagt dazu sind
wir intensiven Gesprächen gerade sie
Debatte fängt ja jetzt heute an es gibt
etwas anderes wir sind ja im Grunde
genommen jetzt schon in der Wechselstube
jetzt zwischen Gas und Strom und das ist
ja auch immer nur zusammen zu denken wir
sie auch festgestellt haben Herr Jung es
gibt eine massive Kritik die auch
durchaus ernstzunehmen ist weil sie auch
ans Konstrukt dran geht die sagt
eigentlich bietet das ganze so wie es
aufgebaut ist nicht genügend Sparanreize
also wenn ich mit einem hohen Wert komme
an Verbrauch habe ich trotzdem diese 80
Prozent die einfach mal einfach
gedeckelt sind und wenn ich bisher schon
gespart habe bringt mir das nicht so
furchtbar viel hätte man das irgendwie
schlauer machen können ich finde das ist
ja die Konstruktion die die Kommission
vorgeschlagen hat eine Deckelung nicht
auf das Niveau vor der Krise sondern auf
ein Niveau des nach der Krise erwartet
wird niemand weiß wie es genau ist aber
es ist doch noch mal erheblich mehr als
vor der Krise und nicht zu 100% sondern
zu 80%, das heißt im guten Teil müssen
Marktpreis sie dann eben doch bezahlt
werden und da hat man bei den aktuellen
Preisen ein spar-anhalt und deshalb im
Grundsatz wie gesagt hätten wir diese
Konstruktion für richtig weil sie
mehrere Dinge zusammenbringt auch
übrigens die Frage wenn wir jetzt als
Stadt Eingreifen was ist in dieser
Situation ausdrücklich notwendig ist wie
kommen wir da wieder raus und wenn diese
Preise die erwartet werden tatsächlich
erreicht werden 12 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde beim Gas dann wird es
automatisch abgeschafft werden deshalb
ja man kann ein Muster über nachdenken
was kann man noch mehr für sparen für
Effizienz tun in
Betrieben und bei Privathaushalten aber
im Grundsatz ist an diesem Punkt die
Konstruktion sehr nachvollziehbar und
ich finde zusätzlich müssen natürlich
auch Investitionen getätigt werden also
es kann ja nicht die Dauerlösung sein
dass sozusagen diese hohen was wir
insgesamt als Gesellschaft gegen diese
hohen Energiepreise an subventionieren
sondern es muss dringend mehr dafür
getan werden das auch Vermieter in die
Sanierung der Häuser investieren weil
die MieterInnen
zweites Feld auf also wir sind alleine
bei den Bremsen bei einem höheren
zweistelligen äh Milliardenbetrag so hat
er gesagt hat 56 oder so statt dem Raum
und da kann natürlich was drauf kommen
es gibt immer so besondere Gruppen die
man manchmal verstehst und dann kommen
sie wieder bisschen rein eine Gruppe
sozusagen die jungen Menschen in
Ausbildung sage ich jetzt einfach mal
ich mache es mal relativ komplett da ist
was schönes angedacht für Studenten
Studentinnen Fachausbildung etc das
ganze ist nur ein bisschen blöd ich muss
das auf einer digitalen Plattform
anmelden die es noch gar nicht gibt Frau
verlinken
es wird umgesetzt und das Geld wird bei
den Menschen ankommen okay jetzt haben
wir wenn wir in den Schlusskurve gehen
Herr Jung noch mal die Chance zu reden
über sagen wir mal unseren Energiemix
der Zukunft es bringt ja nichts wenn du
den heutigen Tag denken ey jetzt haben
wir eine neue Lösung
Qatar will uns Flüssiggas liefern 2026
das ist so ein Sichtweite aber es ist
jetzt nicht direkt was für den nächsten
Winter
wie was machen wir eigentlich aus dieser
Balance von Abhängigkeiten sozusagen
sind wir quasi bei dem einen aus dem
Bett gesprungen und gehen mit dem
nächsten sagen wir mal halb seinen
Bruder zu Bett die Antwort auf
einseitige Abhängigkeiten die bei den
fossilen entstanden sind bei Russland
müssen ganz breite Partnerschaften sein
vor allem beim Wasserstoff die sind ja
auch auf dem Weg gebracht schon in den
letzten Jahren die müssen jetzt
konsequent fortgeführt werden auf dem
Weg dahin brauchen wir Gas als Brücke da
ist wichtig dass eben sehr verteilt wird
dass wir nicht einen oder nur wenige
große Lieferanten haben sondern das
jetzt gelingt er ein ein breiten Strauß
an Lieferbeziehungen aufzubauen aber
entscheidend ist dass wir jetzt die
Dinge die wir angegangen haben
erneuerbare Energien Energieeffizienz
wasserstoffstrategie dass die konsequent
vorangebracht werden dass die
beschleunigt werden mit einem
verlässlichen Rahmen für die
Energieeffizienz aber auch dadurch dass
wir den Erneuerbaren jetzt Vertrauen
geben Verlässlichkeit geben und dieses
Vertrauen wird durch den Vorschlag zur
Abschöpfung beschädigt und deshalb ist
gut das war verlinken angekündigt hat
wie auch Abgeordnete Ampel gestern im
Ausschuss da schaut man noch mehr
gemeinsam drauf so wie es ist kann das
nicht bleiben
solange das Präsidium noch nicht da ist
können wir noch einen Punkt weiter
sprechen also es gibt quasi noch diesen
Punkt mit diesem Flüssigkeit das war ja
kein liebes Mutter für die Grünen und
sie gehen jetzt quasi noch mal
eigentlich den Weg in die falsche
Richtung
es ist wichtig dass diejenigen die jetzt
privatwirtschaftliche Entscheidungen
treffen genau im Blick haben dass wir
ein ja eine Klimaschutzpolitik
fortsetzen die dazu führen wird dass
deutlich weniger gasverbraucht wird in
den nächsten Jahren schon wird der
Gasverbrauch zurückgehen denn ja wir
müssen die Klimaziele schaffen und dazu
führt eben raus aus den fossilen und
deswegen ist die Langfristigkeit von
Investitionsentscheidungen eine sehr
knifflige Angelegenheit wo die
Unternehmen die da rein investieren gut
nachdenken müssen was langfristig
funktioniert ich habe zu danken an Julia
verlinken Andreas Jung sie als Politik
haben noch viel auf der Brust 9 % nur
der Deutschen glauben dass diese
entlastungsorgien wirklich eine
entlastungsbringe am Ende da ist noch
viel Vertrauensarbeit nötig danke dass
Sie bei uns waren meine Damen und Herren
wir wollen jetzt reingehen in der
Deutschen Bundestag gab es die
Parlamentspräsidentin eröffnet
heute morgen der Tag wird heute lang die
Sitzung ist eröffnet
zunächst müssen wir noch eine Wahl
durchführen
in den Beirat bei der Bundesnetzagentur
soll auf Vorschlag der Fraktion der SPD
der Abgeordnete Bernd Westphal als
Nachfolger für den ausgeschiedenen
Abgeordneten Falco Moors als
ordentliches Mitglied gewählt werden ich
sehe keinen Widerspruch
dann ist das der Fall damit ist der
Kollege Westphal als Mitglied gewählt
ich rufe auf
herzlichen Glückwunsch
[Applaus]
ich rufe auf die Tagesordnungspunkte 7a
bis 7D Beratung von Vorlagen zur
Einführung einer Preisbremse für Erdgas
Wärme und Strom sowie einer Studierenden
energiepreispauschale zu dem Entwurf
eines studieren einer Studierenden
Energiepreis pauschalgesetzes liegt ein
Änderungsantrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu
vor
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
68 Minuten vereinbart
ich eröffne nun die Aussprache
und zuerst beginnt für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen Frau Dr Ingrid
Nestle
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir bringen
heute das Gesetz des Paket zur
gaspreisbremse und strompreisbremse ein
die Menschen und Unternehmen in diesem
Land können sich auf die Ampel verlassen
Putin Putin hat diesen Kontinent in eine
sehr schwierige Lage gebracht und
Deutschland durch eine Kombination von
absichtlich hochgetriebenen Preisen für
fossile Energien in Mischung mit einer
Desinformationskampagne daran sein gar
nicht die fossilen oder Putin Schuld
sondern ach wahrscheinlich der neuer
waren oder der Klimaschutz dieses Land
in eine sehr schwierige Lage gebracht
und ja dass sie jetzt hier von ganz
rechten Rand überfahren das ist sehr
bezeichnet denn als ein sie sind sie
diejenigen die Putins
Desinformationskampagne sogar hier
unterstützt und das fügt diesem Land
wirklich schweren Schaden zu
liebe liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
können die Folgen von Putins Angriffen
nicht ausradieren aber wir können sie
sehr wohl mildern wir können dafür
sorgen dass unsere Gesellschaft nicht
daran zerbricht dass der und die
einzelnen nicht allein gelassen sind und
unsere Wirtschaft stabilisiert wird und
da möchte ich mich ganz zuvorderst
bedanken beim Wirtschaft und
Energieministerium die in wirklich
wirklich grandioser sehr harte Arbeit
diese Entwürfe arbeitet haben und ich
finde sie haben eine ganze Reihe sehr
sehr gute Aspekte
erstens die Entlastung kommt automatisch
niemand muss Anträge stellen niemand
muss Formulare ausfüllen nein das Geld
kommt automatisch bei Ihnen zu Hause an
zweitens wer Gas und Strom spart spart
auch weiterhin Geld und ja auch das ist
wichtig denn damit wir gut durch diesen
und den nächsten Winter kommen ist es
weiterhin wichtig dass wir alle
gemeinsam auf Solidarität ich saß noch
mal weil es hier ständig falsch
unterstellt wird nicht die Leute mit
wenig Geld müssen sparen weil sie kein
Geld haben wir alle als Gesellschaft
auch gerade die Reichen in Solidarität
denn mit wir mit den knappen Gas durch
diesen und den nächsten Winter kommen
müssen wir Gas und Strom sparen und
deswegen ist es richtig und wichtig dass
in diesem Entwurf dafür gesorgt wird
dass diejenige die das tun auch
tatsächlich wahres Geld behalten
drittens finde ich es sehr gut dass mit
diesem Gesetz alle entlastet werden
Menschen Unternehmen Kommunen und ohne
eine komplizierte Unterscheidung wer zu
welcher Gruppe gehört nein wir gucken
lediglich was sind die Gruppe mit hohen
Verbrauch was ist die mit niedrigen
Verbrauch und ich halte diesen Ansatz
für sehr intelligent und sehr effizient
er sorgt für klare Kommunikation und
macht die Umsetzung in so kurzer Zeit
überhaupt erst möglich
wichtig ist uns auch
dass die Subventionen bei den Reichen
besteuert wird das Jahr das gerade
besonders viel Geld bei denen ankommt
die wenig davon haben das besonders viel
dort ankommt wo es am dringendsten
benötigt wird
wir werden uns
wir werden uns darüber hinaus im
parlamentarischen Verfahren dafür
einsetzen dass auch die Unternehmen die
sehr große Unterstützung bekommen in
dieser Zeit keine Boni und
dividendenausschützen für ausschütten
dürfen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen dieses
Gesetzespaket organisiert Solidarität
und dazu gehört auch dass diejenigen die
sehr hohe Gewinne gemacht haben durch
die hohen Energiepreise ihren Beitrag
leisten in einem anderen Gesetz dass wir
nicht hier diskutieren geht es dabei um
die Gewinne der Ölkonzerne hier und
heute geht es um die Gewinne im
Strombereich
und dort werden alle alle relevanten
stromerzeugungstechnologien abgeschöpft
bei denen etwas abzuschöpfen gibt und ja
das sind nicht Gas und Steinkohle Gas
ganz evident deshalb nicht weil wir
weniger Gaskraftwerke mit teuren Gas
überhaupt dieses ganze Problem haben da
ist nichts abzuschöpfen aber auch die
Steinkohle ist sehr wäre sehr wenig zu
holen würden wie dieses wenige holen
bestünde die ernste Gefahr dass
tatsächlich wieder viel mehr
Gaskraftwerke statt der Kohlekraftwerke
laufen dass wir viel mehr Gas
verbrauchen in eine mangelage Rauschen
und das wäre kritisch
es wird mitunter behauptet wir würden am
meisten bei der Erneuerbaren holen nein
wir besteuern hier oder wir schöpfen
nicht explizit bei den Erneuerbaren ab
wir schöpfen bei allen
stromerzeugungstechnologien ab wo es
geht aber ja die Erneuerbaren liefern
tatsächlich am meisten weil die
Erneuerbaren den größten Anteil an der
Stromversorgung stellen und weil sie bei
weitem am kostengünstigsten sind und das
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen sind zwei
sehr gute Nachrichten
sie zeigen sie zeigen auch wie dringend
für die Erneuerbaren brauchen für die
Zukunft für die preisgünstigkeit für die
Versorgungssicherheit für den
Klimaschutz und deswegen legen wir
großen Wert darauf mit diesem
Gesetzespaket auch gute
Investitionsbedingungen für die Zukunft
für die Erneuerbaren zu schaffen hier
wird nichts abgeschöpft wir haben gute
sicherheitsmarschen festgelegt das kann
man vielleicht schon daran sehen dass
wir von geschätzten 90 Milliarden
Zufalls gewinnen 20 Milliarden
abschöpfen ja wir brauchen die
Erneuerbaren und wichtig ist vor allem
dass wir gute Investitionsbedingungen
für die Zukunft schaffen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es wird
auch manchmal gesagt warum gibt es zwei
unterschiedliche Werte für Braunkohle
das gucken wir uns an genau wie die
Werte für Atom ich sage nur schon mal
diejenigen die sich beschweren das
andere mehr kriegen die können selbst in
Kohleausstieg auf 20 30 vorziehen dann
bekommen Sie auch den hören werden
ich komme zum Abschluss dieses Gesetz
kann nicht perfekt sein würden wir auf
das perfekte Gesetz warten würden wir
gar nichts beschließen und die Menschen
Unternehmen in diesem Land allein lassen
das Gesetz kann nicht perfekt sein aber
es macht diese Regierung auch dass sie
trotzdem handelt wo Handeln notwendig
ist und das ist ein großes Glück für
unser Land in dieser Zeit Putin hat sich
das anders gedacht er hat gehofft dass
unsere Demokratie schon in diesem Winter
zusammenbricht aber die Menschen in
diesem Land sind bereit für Solidarität
unser Land ist stark und die Ampel ist
bereits die notwendige Unterstützung zu
organisieren herzlichen Dank
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Andreas Jung
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Energiepreise sind
explodiert vor allem weil putinen
Energie als Waffe gegen uns einsetzt dem
müssen wir die Stirn bieten und deshalb
ist es richtig und notwendig zu
begrenzen zu decken zu bremsen als Union
fordern wir seit Monaten diese Preis
bremsen und soweit sie umgesetzt werden
unterstützen wir das Trinken wir darauf
dass sie beschleunigt umgesetzt werden
und darauf dass es klare Regelungen gibt
insoweit haben Sie unsere Unterstützung
aber die Art und Weise wie sie es
umsetzen er Finanzminister die wirft
viele Fragen auf wir machen es in
Deutschland komplizierter als alle
anderen in Europa es ist ein gemeinsames
europäisches Vorhaben Preise zu
begrenzen wir machen es aber
komplizierter als alle anderen wenn sie
so umsetzen dann werden wir zum
Europameister für bürokratische
Umsetzung und das kann nicht sein
deshalb muss der nachgebessert werden
deshalb müssen die Regelung klarer
werden und Herr Lindner ich frage mich
sie machen diese komplizierten
Regelungen sie sind doch der
Finanzminister doch sie sind zuständig
für die Mehrwertsteuer warum warum Herr
Lindner geben Sie nicht ein ganz klares
Signal die Mehrwertsteuer wird gesenkt
für alle und zwar nicht für die beim Gas
und für Fernwärme aber beim Strom
wiederum nicht beim Öl auch nicht eine
klare Botschaft dafür sind sie zuständig
setzen sie sich um Mehrwertsteuer runter
für alle Energieträger das wäre ein
wichtiger
und wir unterstützen strompreisbremse
wir unterstützen gaspreisbremse aber wir
sind gegen die Erneuerbaren Bremse die
da vorgelegt wird was sie hier machen
Ingrid Nestler gerade von
Investitionssicherheit gesprochen das
beschädigt des Vertrauen in
Investitionen in erneuerbare Energien
und die werden jetzt schon
zurückgestellt und oh doch es ist so
dass erneuerbare in diesem Paket
schlechter behandelt werden es die
fossilen schlechter behandelt werden als
die Kernenergie nirgends soll so
abgeschöpft werden wie bei den
erneuerbaren Energien und das darf nicht
sein da habe ich wollte
Herr Habig und die Ampel wollte doch mit
dem osterpaket den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien beschleunigen das
wird mit diesem Winter eingerissen es
wird Vertrauen beschädigen deshalb muss
man da noch mal ran und ich will ihnen
sagen in welchen Punkten
gerade ist gesprochen würden wir
schöpfen Gewinne ab ne das ist nicht
richtig bei den großen Konzernen
Mineralöl Gas da werden Gewinne
abgeschafft aber hier werden Erträge
abgeschöpft es werden fiktive Erträge
abgeschöpft was vermutlich
verfassungswidrig ist ist aber
jedenfalls in der Sache falsch weil
damit Geld abgeschöpft wird es ist in
vielen Fällen gar nicht gibt nehmen Sie
die Bioenergie sie nehmen die Steinkohle
aus die CO2 ausstoßende Steinkohle aber
die nachhaltige Bioenergie die wird so
gedeckelt dass die Grundlage für den
weiteren Betrieb in Frage gestellt ist
und deshalb müssen sie da noch mehr
Range brauchen eine tragfähige Grundlage
für die Bioenergie das was danach
gebessert wurde reicht bei weitem nicht
die haben Kostensteigerung in ganz
erheblichem Umfang das muss
berücksichtigt werden gehen sie da noch
mal an wir brauchen einen Grundlage für
ein beschleunigtenausbau der
Erneuerbaren und keine dicke Kinder der
erneuerbaren Energien
und dasselbe gilt für die Kraft
wärmekopplung die Kraft wärmekupplung
ist der verlässliche Partner für
volatile erneuerbare Energien und den
entziehen sie jetzt rückwirkend die
Grundlage dadurch dass sie die
Netzentgelte die die bisher nicht
bezahlen müssen die sollen die jetzt
bezahlen und damit werden vermutlich
viele dieser Anlagen abgestellt werden
und ausfallen in einer Situation in der
wie Sie gerade brauchen besser sieht es
nach wir brauchen hier Verlässlichkeit
wir brauchen Vertrauen und wir brauchen
im übrigen parlamentarische Entscheidung
und nicht die Delegation wichtiger
Entscheidung an diese Regierung sie
legen hier vor ein Gesetz in dem sie die
Bundesregierung
ermächtigen wollen zu entscheiden ob das
was sie zur Abschöpfung vorliegen ob das
7 Monate gilt oder 17 Monate sieben
Monate oder 17 Monate meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren da ist doch
der kernparlam Herrscher Bestimmung
gefragt ich appelliere an ihr
Selbstverständnis als Abgeordnete nehmen
Sie hier parlamentarische Rechte weil es
kann nicht sein dass die Regierung Herr
Lindner er Habeck und Olaf Scholz in der
Suppenküche der Bundesregierung darüber
entscheiden ob 7 oder 17 Monate bei
erneuerbaren Energien abgeschaffte das
muss hier entschieden werden hier
schlägt das Herz der Demokratie ist eine
parlamentarische Entscheidung und
deshalb im Grundsatz Strom und Gaspreis
können Sie richtig falsch dass sie ganze
Gruppen ausschließen bei Pellets und
beim Öl da muss was gemacht werden aber
insbesondere müssen sie da noch mehr ran
wir brauchen eine Verlässlichkeit wir
brauchen Vertrauen dass es entscheiden
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion dr
Matthias Miersch
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lieber Kollege jung das ist
richtig dass die Opposition auch Dinge
anmerkt aber von Suppenküche etc zu
reden von Suppenküche etc zu reden das
ist schon ein bisschen sage ich mal wenn
man sich die Konzeption der CDU und CSU
der letzten Monate mal in diesem Haus
anguckt was die Bewältigung dieser Krise
anbelangt dann wäre ich an ihrer Stelle
ein bisschen vorsichtiger das erste was
diese Regierung und diese Koalition
geleistet hat ist dass wir
Versorgungssicherheit sicherstellen und
das ist ein ganz wesentlicher Schritt
was für eine putzbecher Merz schön dass
sie jetzt auch da sind sie kritisieren
die Gaslieferung aus Katar hätten wir
Ihrem Vorschlag im März gefolgt ein Gas
embargo auszusprechen während wir jetzt
in einer katastrophalen gasmangelage sie
hätten das Land an die Wand gefahren
und da wir das Thema
Versorgungssicherheit so gut wie möglich
jetzt geregelt haben machen wir heute
den Aufschlag um den zweiten wichtigen
Punkt zur Bewältigung dieser Krise zu
bewerkstelligen nämlich das Thema
Bezahlbarkeit und auch ja Andreas Jung
da sind wir selbstbewusste
Parlamentarier wir gucken uns jetzt
diesen Gesetzesentwurf einschließlich
der Bremsen und der damit verbundenen
Problematiken an aber was man hier sagen
muss ist das was sie hier gemacht haben
als es um die Finanzierungsfrage dieser
Bremse geht sie haben nicht zugestimmt
ohne ihn hätten wir ohne sie hätten wir
mit ihnen hätten wir überhaupt gar kein
Geld diese Bremsen jetzt zu organisieren
sie waren gegen die 200 Milliarden
deswegen kann ich nur sagen es war für
unsere Fraktion sehr sehr wichtig dass
wir neben dem 100 Milliarden
entlastungspaketen jetzt einen
systemischen Eingriff in die
Preisbildung vonnehmen und damit
schaffen wir Sicherheit für
verbraucherne und Verbraucher und für
weite Teile der Wirtschaft aber zur
Wahrheit gehört auch wir Bremsen auf das
Niveau so dass das Doppelte im Vergleich
zum vorkriegszeitraum immer noch zu
stemmen ist insofern ist das Thema
Einsparung von Energie nach wie vor eins
was uns alle angeht
aber das zentrale ist dass wir ein
System haben was nun kalkulierbar für
die Zeit bis April 24 ist klar ist und
ich weiß dass Dietmar Bartsch mit
Sicherheit auch darauf hinweisen wird es
wird keine Einzelfallgerechtigkeit bei
einem solchen Gesetz geben aber der
Anspruch ist schon dass wir versuchen so
gut wie möglich und so zielgenau wie
möglich dieses Gesetz zu formulieren und
deswegen
und deswegen will ich hier ein paar
Punkte benennen ja
augenblicklich und das war zentrale
Aufgabe der Kommission richten wir uns
an gastkunden aber wir wissen dass es
auch Härten im Bereich von ölpellets und
Flüssigkeits gibt insofern wollen wir
uns auch eine Regelung für diese
Abfederung ausdenken und sie kreieren
das wird die Aufgabe der nächsten 14
Tage für die Parlamentarier in diesem
Raum sein
der zweite wichtige Punkt ist die
Versorger haben in der Kommission der
sehr deutlich gemacht dass sie nicht
wissen wer sich hinter einem Anschluss
verbirgt das ist die große
Herausforderung so zielgenau wie möglich
zu sein und deswegen nehmen wir uns vor
auch bis April 24 zu überlegen welche
Daten brauchen wir um dann zielgenau im
Zweifel zu steuern und auch zu
unterstützen und wenn wir es jetzt nicht
ganz schnell schaffen für diesen Winter
dann ist zumindestens der Herbst und der
Winter 23 24 dann der Zeitpunkt wo wir
noch zielgenauer noch gerechter noch
besser werden liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und zudem geht es ja Andreas Jung aber
das nun gerade ausgerechnet die cdu/csu
die Erneuerbaren entdeckt hat okay man
lernt dazu aber es geht natürlich darum
dass wir hier nicht Investitionen
abwürgen im Bereich der erneuerbaren und
deswegen ist das Thema Biogas ein Thema
was wir uns in den nächsten zwei Wochen
auch noch mal vornehmen werden um hier
keine Fehlsteuerung zu produzieren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
für diese Koalition ist somit
entscheidend dass wir Krise bewältigen
Versorgungssicherheit und Bezahlbarkeit
sicherstellen aber den dritten Punkt den
dürfen wir nicht vernachlässigen und wir
vernachlässigen in auch nicht in dieser
Krise muss das neue gleichzeitig massiv
zum Durchbruch verhalten werden und
insofern ist der massive Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien der Punkt den wir
genauso auf diese Tagesordnung setzen
dann wird die Krise bewältigen mit einer
zukunftsrichtung darauf kommt es an
vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
und dies für die Koalition der
stellvertonationsvorsitzende Matthias
Mirsch nächster Redner Steffen cotré
afd-fraktion das ganze hier in
beschleunigten Verfahren dieses
Gesetzesvorhaben für die Bremsen das ist
ehrgeizig noch vor dem
parlamentarischen Winterpause
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
liebe Besucher liebe Zuschauer im Land
Frau Dr Nestler ich muss einfach mal ein
bisschen Wasser in den
propagandistischen weingießen heute
morgen hatten wir
Gigawatt Leistung und zwar von den
fossilen und lediglich 5 Gigawatt die
aus erneuerbaren Quellen standen und so
viel zum Thema die Erneuerbaren könnten
hier unser Land also mit Strom versorgen
übrigens von den 61 waren 20 GB Gas und
so viel auch zum Thema dass man die
Kernkraftwerke nicht anstellen möchte
die Gesetze zu den Preis Bremsen sind
einem Volksverdummung wie wir sie seit
Erich Honecker nicht mehr hatten die
Ampelkoalition zerstört erst die Gas und
Stromversorgung macht Strom und Gas so
teuer wie nie und wie sonst nirgends
dann stellt sie uns 200 Milliarden
Finanzierung aus den Steuergeldern um
den Brand einzudämmen den sie selbst
gelegt hat aber liebe
liebe Zuschauer lassen sich da nicht an
der Nase herumführen die 200 Milliarden
Euro könnten für Soziales für Schulen
für Zukunftstechnologie ausgegeben
werden aber mit dieser Ampel Koalition
haben wir ein Abrissunternehmen und mit
dieser Regierung haben wir in der links
grüne trümmertruppe die Deutschland
Schritt für Schritt leider abschafft
meine Damen und Herren
und mal zum Vergleich in der Schweiz
liegt der Strompreis
2023 bei 25 Cent bei uns beträgt der 45
bis 60 Cent also das Doppelte die
Inflationsrate beträgt 3,5 Prozent bei
uns mit 10%, das Dreifache woran liegt
das die Schweiz hat eine Regierung die
der Bevölkerung verpflichtet ist im
übrigen haben Sie auch direkt die
Demokratie wir haben eine Regierung die
die die der USA China dem
Internationalen Währungsfonds der EU
Marokko oder anderen verpflichtet ist
die USA und China bekommen gerade von
uns ganze Industriezweige geschenkt weil
deutsche Unternehmen zu preiswerten
energiestandorten Wechseln der IWF
bekommt zig Milliarden für sinnlose
klimamaßnahmen um diese dann in der
ganzen Welt zu verteilen in der EU
zahlen wir für green Deal und die
Wirtschafts- und
gesellschaftstransformation die uns
Planwirtschaft und Bevormundung beschert
in Marokko wird gerade das Finanzsystem
reformiert und wir Steuerzahler dürfen
uns an deren Kosten beteiligen
Vaterlands liebe meine Damen und Herren
Vaterlands Liebe findet augenscheinlich
nun die gesamte
Ampelkoalition zum kotzen und den
Ministern ist es egal was die Wähler
denken
bis 2060 werden wir und unsere
Nachkommen den infantilen doppelwumms
also den doppelt dummen Wumms wenn man
so will noch bezahlen müssen die
Verpflichtung Deutschlands mit jetzt
schon mehr als 14 Billionen Euro sind
ohnehin nicht mehr ohne
entschädigungslose Enteignungen durch
Inflation oder
diebstahlrückzahlbar wir drohen Zustände
zu bekommen wie ein Diktaturen also wo
Stabilität Eigentum Freiheit
wirtschaftliche Entfaltungsmöglichkeiten
nichts mehr zählen meine Damen und
Herren und ab jetzt ausgehandelten
gasziel mit
Qatar lässt sich das Ganze versagen und
die ganze
veruntreuungspolitik der linksgrünen
trümmertruppe festmachen obwohl sich
abwicklungs ab Wirtschaftsminister habe
vor dem Scheiß was auf dem Boden
geworfen hat werden wir nur magere 2%
unserer Versorgungslücke damit schließen
können und das auch erst ab 2026
russisches Gas verweigern aber keine
Alternative haben also das ist das
Niveau meines zweijährigen Sohnes der
also sein Nuckel wegschmeißt und sich
dann wundert dass er nicht mehr nuckeln
kann
Weg hören Chaos überall die Erstattung
der vermiedenen Netzentgelte wird
abgeschafft aber mit dieser abstattung
kalkulierten kleinere dezentrale
Stromerzeuger die Stadtwerke zum
Beispiel die nun ein Teil ihrer
Investition nicht mehr abdecken können
mit dieser
unvorhergesehenen Streichung nimmt man
natürlich auch ein Stück
Rechtssicherheit hier in Deutschland weg
und ja wie lange wird dieses
zusammengeschusterte Konglomerat an
Regelungen halten bevor es also das
Bundesverfassungsgericht wieder kassiert
wenn das dann so kommt dann stehen
unsere Menschen hier im Land leider im
Regen und die soziale Schieflage ist
vorprogrammiert meine Damen und Herren
nein die Lösung ist ganz einfach
Ausdehnung des künstlich verknappten
Angebotes und damit Senkung der Preise
das spart Geld anstatt ist den
Steuerzahlern wegzunehmen alle Kohle und
Kernkraftwerke ans Netz Nord Stream 2
muss für Gasimporte geöffnet werden ganz
einfach meine Damen und Herren die
Ampelkoalition die ist ein
Abrissunternehmen und Deutschland leider
das Opfer aber das wird den Menschen
nicht lange verborgen bleiben nach
Abwicklung der links grüne Politik meine
Damen und Herren nach Beendigung der
Politik der verbrannten Erde bauen wird
Deutschland wieder auf
meine Damen und Herren so weiter
Redebeitrag von Steffen coutrey er sitzt
für die AFD im Ausschuss für Klimaschutz
und Energie es war sozusagen eine
frontale Breitseite gegen alles was hier
vorgebracht wurde aber gegen Vorschläge
war nicht in dieser Rede Lukas Köhler
jetzt stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzender der FDP
Bundestagsfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren
lieber Kollege sie sind ja eingestiegen
in ihre Debatte gerade in ihrer Rede
dass wir zu viel Kohle im Netz haben und
ausgestiegen sie sind wie dass wir nicht
genug Kohle im Netz haben ich glaube das
einzige was sie sich mit ihrer Rede
gerade verdient haben ist das
fleißbienchen aus Moskau aber sonst gar
nicht tut mir leid
es tut mir leid was sie gerade
aufgezählt haben ist doch absurd ja es
ist richtig wir haben gerade sehr viel
mehr Kohle im im Stromsystem warum damit
wir für eine ausreichende
Versorgungssicherheit sorgen natürlich
argumentieren und gehen wir davon aus
dass wir in jeder Zeit zu jeder Stunde
an jedem Tag ausreichend Strom brauchen
und deswegen ist dieser energiekrieg den
Putin gegen Deutschland und Europa führt
das was uns zu all den Maßnahmen die wir
jetzt angehen zwingt es soll nicht weil
wir denken Mensch super lass uns mehr
Kohle aus der Reserve holen oder lass
uns insgesamt 300 Milliarden an die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dieses Landes
geben damit sie mit den Preisen
klarkommen die dadurch entstehen sind
wir sind gezwungen zu diesen Maßnahmen
wir sind gezwungen dazu das zu tun was
wir gerade umsetzen und zwar weil es
einen Krieg in der Ukraine gibt und weil
es ein Krieg gegen dieses Land durch
Vladimir Putin auf der Energie und
Wirtschaftsseite gibt und ja wir helfen
den Ukraine und ja die Ukraine wird
gewinnen und ja wir werden durch diesen
Winter kommen dadurch dass wir den
Menschen helfen dass wir der Industrie
dass wir der Wirtschaft helfen dass wir
dafür sorgen dass Gas und Kohle günstig
genug bleibt Kollege gestatten sie eine
Zwischenfrage oder Zwischenbemerkung von
Herrn Vahle nein danke nein
wir haben uns auf der Angebotsseite
vorgenommen gehabt dafür zu sorgen dass
das da ist was nötig ist die Speicher
sind voll die Kohlekraftwerke gehen
wieder ins Netz die Kernkraftwerke
laufen bis in den April und versorgen
uns mit ausreichend Strom wir müssen
aber natürlich auch an die preisseite
denken und ja es gibt eine Menge Herten
und deswegen ist es richtig dass wir uns
dafür entschieden haben einen oder zwei
Instrumente zu wählen die einfach
wirksam und unbürokratisch sind und ja
damit kann man nicht immer zielgenau
sein ja da gibt es Probleme und Fehler
aber ja was auch richtig ist und da bin
ich Robert Habeck dafür sehr dankbar
dass er diesen Vorschlag hier vorliegt
zur strompreisbremse zur gaspreisbremse
weil es ist richtig und es ist wichtig
dass wir diese Maßnahmen jetzt einführen
dass die Menschen unterstützt werden
dass sie unternehmen dass sie Industrie
weiterlaufen kann dass die ökonomische
Fähigkeit dieses Landes erhalten wird
und deswegen ist es gut dass wir diese
Maßnahmen und trotzdem bringen sie die
sparenreize die wir brauchen denn wir
müssen über diesen Winter kommen und wir
müssen für den nächsten vorbereitet sein
und trotzdem ist es gut und richtig dass
wir ein Instrument gefunden haben mit
der gaspreisbremse dass die Kosten so
senkt dass wir vorwärts
und es ist auch wichtig dass wir uns bei
der strompreisbremse sehr intensiv jetzt
auch im parlamentarischen Verfahren noch
mal angucken was da passiert das bmwk
hat einen Vorschlag vorgelegt mit dem
man sehr gut arbeiten kann ich glaube es
gibt eine Reihe von technischen Fragen
die wir klären müssen sowohl auf der
Seite des auszahlungsmechanismus aber
vor allen Dingen auf Seite der Art des
abschöpfungsmailismus es ist klar dass
das ein ganz neues Instrument ist und
neue Instrumente sind in der Politik
fehleranfällig natürlich das ist ganz
normal es gibt Probleme und
Herausforderungen insbesondere wenn wir
Dinge sehr schnell sehr zielgerichtet
machen müssen und ja wir müssen darüber
nachdenken dass wir zum Beispiel neue
Anlagen von der Abschöpfung ausnehmen
weil wir dürfen mit der Preis Bremse
keine Investitionsbremse schaffen wir
dürfen nicht dafür sorgen dass in neue
Technologien in neue Anlagen nicht im
nächsten Jahr investiert wird und
deswegen glaube ich dass wir dafür
machen müssen und ja auch im Bereich der
Bioenergie kann man noch einiges machen
aber man muss auch dazu sagen wir haben
die europäische Ebene die zwingt uns
dazu eine ganze Reihe von Dingen zu tun
und deswegen müssen wir und können wir
dafür sorgen dass wir an den richtigen
Stellen Entlastung schaffen aber wir
brauchen natürlich auch die Einnahmen
und das gewährt diese Abschöpfung dieses
Instrument das gewährt uns die
Möglichkeit gezielt zu handeln die
Preise zu senken und dafür zu sorgen
dass an der richtigen Stelle das
richtige Geld ankommt wir werden im
parlamentarischen Verfahren Verfahren
dieses Gesetz noch besser machen wir
werden die technischen Fragen klären wir
werden dafür sorgen dass richtige
Investitionsanreiz an der richtigen
Stelle sind ich freue mich auf die
weiteren Verhandlungen vielen Dank
Lukas Köhler hat das angerissen es ist
noch einiges zu tun in diesen nächsten
zwei Wochen wenn das alles so gut
gelingen kann dann könnte zum 16
Dezember im Bundesrat das ganze
abschließend über die Bühne gehen im
parlamentarischen Verfahren
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
ich will den Vorredner nur mal sagen ihr
müsste doch bekannt sein das vor sechs
Jahren Herr Habeck gefordert hat
keinerlei Gas mehr und Rohstoffe aus
Russland zu holen dafür gibt es Videos
die seine Äußerungen aufgezeichnet haben
jetzt müssten sie doch glücklich sein
weil er habe geschafft hat was erreicht
hat und dann faseln sie etwas davon das
Putin Gas als Druckmittel nutzt sondern
ihre grünen Link Vorstellung sind halt
linkes falsch aber ihre grünen falschen
Vorstellungen sind doch alle ja die sind
doch die FDP von heute ist doch nichts
anderes als der Wurmfortsatz dieser
grünen Partei und dann fahren Sie hier
etwas von dem Krieg von Moskau der hier
unser Gast erreicht es werden doch ihre
Träume verwirklicht die verschleudern
das Geld der Menschen und damit komme
ich auch schon zum Schluss erzählen sie
den Leuten doch nicht so ein Unsinn
diese Krise die wir in der
Energiepolitik haben haben sie als
Ampelkoalition selbst herbeigeführt
vielen Dank
soweit die Kurzintervention Robert fahle
war mein Mitglied der afd-fraktion und
ist jetzt fraktionslos möchte Lukas
Köhler entgegnen ja möchte
mehr brauche ich dazu nicht zu sagen
das war umfassende nächste Redner hat
sich auch bereits bereit gemacht das ist
Dietmar Bartsch der Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Linken mal schauen ob Bärbel Basis
noch mal aufnimmt
jetzt kann ich aber den nächsten Redner
aufrufen für die Fraktion DIE LINKE dr
Dietmar Bartsch
Mikroanlage plus Herr köhlerischen
ziemlich genial ja Frau Präsident meine
Damen und Herren Freunde sie haben hier
gesprochen von grandios und Umsetzungen
so kurzer Zeit ehrlich gesagt das kann
ich so ganz nachvollziehen also noch im
Sommer hat diese Regierung eine
gasumlage angekündigt während andere
Länder in Europa schon lange die
Energiepreise gedeckelt haben und sich
auf den Winter vorbereitet haben haben
sie noch über höhere Preise spartoniert
das ist doch die Wahrheit deswegen muss
ich ja habe doch die Frage gefallen
lassen warum erst jetzt warum reden wir
heute das erste Mal über dieses Thema
nach Monaten 9 Monaten nach Beginn des
fürchterlichen Krieges die Wahrheit ist
doch spät später habe ich so wie sie
heute zu spät gekommen sind das ist die
Wahrheit meine Damen und Herren beide
beide Strom und gaspreisbremse hätten
lange da sein müssen die Menschen und
die Unternehmen in Deutschland zahlen
letztlich für ihre zu spät Politik
einhören Preis ja natürlich ist doch
völlig unbestritten das Gas den
strompreisbremsen geeignete Maßnahmen
sind die explodierenden Energiepreise
einzudämmen und ist auch richtig dort
ist das dort entsprechende mittelbreit
gestellt wird völlig unstrittig aber es
ist eben nicht nur viel später es ist
auch noch mangelhaft ihre bremsen würde
kein TÜV in Deutschland anerkennen meine
Damen und Herren weil
erstens sind die Bremsen zu hoch
zweitens sind sie eine Einladung zum
Abkassieren drittens sind sie sozial
zutiefst ungerecht und viertens sind sie
Schmieröl für die Gewinne der
Energiekonzern wir mit dem ersten Beginn
40 Cent pro Kilowattstunde beim Strom
die sind natürlich deutlich zu hoch das
ist im Moment erstmal überhaupt keine
Bremse sondern aktuell ist das ein
Gaspedal zumindest bei den strombremsen
beim Strompreisen gebremst gebremst
wurde realen in Österreich da sind das
10 Cent pro haushaltskontingen das wäre
eine Bremse 10 Cent meine Damen und
Herren
wenn die strompreisbremse bei 40 Cent
ansetzt dann ist das doch logisch dass
kein Versorger darunter bleibt warum
warum kontrollieren sie dann nicht die
Preise wenn sie bei 40 Cent die Rechnung
übernehmen müssen sie doch sich von den
Versorgern erklären lassen wieso der
eine 53% und der andere vielleicht 66
Prozent nimmt das kann doch nicht wahr
sein ohne staatliche Preiskontrollen
sind Strom und gaspreisbremsen eine
Einladung zum Abkassieren meine Damen
und Herren das ist die Wahrheit und
lieber Matthias Hirsch zu Recht darauf
hingewiesen das Hauptproblem ist die
soziale Ungerechtigkeit wir alle hier
und alle anderen gut Verdiener
profitieren doch von den Bremsen am
meisten das ist doch die Wahrheit mehr
als die Bevölkerung ansonsten es kann
doch nicht wahr sein ich will den
Wirtschaftsminister zitieren er hat
gesagt gerecht wäre dass sie besonders
bedürftig sind besonders viel bekommen
aber das Gegenteil ist doch der Fall wer
in diesem Jahr werden in diesem Jahr
gespart hat oder sparen musste weil er
gar nicht anders konnte der bekommt so
gut wie gar nichts
je höher der Verbrauch desto gehören die
Entlastung das ist doch die Wahrheit und
das bedeutet für eine Villa hat und wer
jetzt vielleicht im spätherz noch ein
paar Bahnen im Außenpool schwimmt der
bekommt eben viel viel mehr das ist
sozialpolitischer Wahnsinn ihre Gas und
strompreisbremse ist Umverteilung von
unten nach oben Essen Katalysator für
soziale Ungerechtigkeit das ist die
Wahrheit meine Damen und manche können
nicht mehr sparen manche können einfach
nicht mehr schlafen und wir haben ja
Alternativen vorgeschlagen mit den
bürgerkontingen ich muss das jetzt alles
sehr abkürzen weil ich noch eine
Bemerkung zu den Energiekonzern machen
will ich meine sie haben angekündigt die
Gewinne abzuschöpfen ja Investitionen
schützen das ist alles unbestritten aber
ehrlich gesagt auch da kommt doch viel
viel weniger auf einmal jetzt erst ab
Dezember das war doch mal anders
vorgesehen 50 Milliarden Euro allein den
Stromkunden wurde in diesem Jahr aus der
Tasche gezogen warum wird das denn nicht
wieder zurück um verteilt holen Sie sich
das Geld zurück bei der Ampel läuft
real,-
wer hat Angst vor Christian Lindner das
ist ist die Wahrheit das ist die
Wahrheit wer hat Angst vor Christian
Lindner das machen sie sie immer wenn
dort blockiert wird haben sie keinen Mut
mehr deswegen reparieren sie ihre
Bremsen dem Sie unsere Vorschläge auf
niedrige Deckel festes Kontingent
Preiskontrollen und eine ordentliche
übergewinnsteuer meine Damen und Herren
herzlichen Dank
Dietmar Barsch der Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Linken im Deutschen Bundestag hier
auch noch mal mit einem Plädoyer für das
Gerechtigkeitsprinzip innerhalb der
Bremsen und eine deutliche Nachbesserung
im parlamentarischen Prozess
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin am 21
oktober haben SPD Grüne und FDP hier
gemeinsam dem Abwehrschirm von 200
Milliarden Euro Gaspreis
strompreisbremse beschlossen wer Herr
Merz wäre jung hat dagegen gestimmt es
war die Union in den Haushaltsberatungen
haben sie keine Alternativen
Finanzierungsvorschläge unterbracht sie
sind kein verlässlicher Partner für die
Unternehmen und die Menschen in
Landwasser Sicherheit angeht sie haben
dieser historischen Situation versagt
die preisbremsen sind das richtige
wirtschaftspolitische Instrument um den
energieangriff von Russland abzuwehren
Militär und auch Wirtschaftshilfen
Richtung Ukraine sind das richtige
Instrument um dort zu helfen dass die
Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnen kann und
Russland diesen Krieg verliert auch das
ist in unserem Interesse
Unternehmen bekommen mit diesen Preis
Bremsen schnell und unbürokratisch
finanzielle Unterstützung es sind keine
Anträge nötig die Energieversorger
reduzieren direkt die Rechnung
ganz wichtig wir behalten die
energieeinsparanreize bei und zwar ab
der ersten Kilowattstunde die
preisbremsen sind klug konzipiert die
finanzielle Unterstützung erfolgt als
eine Art Gutschrift die praktisch
unabhängig vom Verbrauch ist und deshalb
gilt weiterhin einsparen lohnt sich das
ist auch sehr wichtig dass eingespart
wird nicht nur für die
Versorgungssicherheit in diesem Land
sondern auch dass wir die Preise runter
kriegen das geht nur indem wir mehr
einsparen auch in diesem Winter und auch
im kommenden Winter
ganz wichtig wir schaffen jetzt Planungs
und Investitionssicherheit das ist
wichtig für den Bäcker in München Pasing
oder die BürgerInnen in Traunstein die
auf eine Wärmepumpe jetzt installieren
will ganz wichtig aber auch im kommenden
Jahr werden wir massiv in den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien investieren und
diesen forcieren Energieeffizienz
Einsparungen dort auf uns konzentrieren
heute morgen hatte ich eine Runde mit
Kolleginnen zum Inflation redakt der
Amerikaner dort ist ein
Investitionsprogramm im Rahmen von Open
End im Prinzip 800 Milliarden Euro
vorgesehen das heißt das race to the top
das beginnt jetzt erst weltweit wer am
stärksten ist im Haus bei der Neubauern
Energie in der stärkt auch die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit in Deutschland und
darum geht es jetzt ganz zentral
zu den Rahmenbedingungen in der Energie
und Gas und strompreisbremse der
Weiterverkauf von Gas bleibt möglich und
das ist auch wichtig für Wirtschaften
ArbeitnehmerInnen denn so schaffen wir
die höchsten Effizienzen wir haben eine
arbeitsplatzerhaltungspflicht hier
verankert im Gesetzesentwurf das werden
wir nochmal in der Ausgestaltung prüfen
es ist wichtig dass auch die Menschen
darauf vertrauen können wenn Unternehmen
profitieren bleiben Arbeitsplätze
erhalten
wichtig ist auch keiner soll übermäßig
von den Bremsen profitieren deswegen
Stellen Höchstgrenzen sicher dass nur
Unternehmen die Hilfen erhalten die sie
dann auch wirklich benötigen die
besonders hart getroffen sind und diese
Bremsen müssen auch europäisch
abgestimmt sein das heißt die
europäischen Partner dürfen wir nicht
vergessen wir haben volle Gasspeicher
das ist gut aber die sind auch in einem
europäischen Verbund das heißt
europäisch zu handeln auch darauf wird
es zentral ankommenden kommenden
Wochenden Monaten wir handeln jetzt hier
sehr entschlossen schaffen Sicherheit
helfen den Unternehmen und im nächsten
Jahr kommt das Jahr wo wir dann die
Wettbewerbsbedingungen auch für die
Industrie für die Wirtschaft zentral
voranbringen werden mit erneuerbaren
Energien Energieeffizienz darauf kommt
es jetzt an ich danke Ihnen
wir hatten gerade an Pult für die
Koalition Dieter Janecek von der Bündnis
90 grünen Fraktion also alles was jetzt
noch nicht passgenau ist so hat er
versprochen wird hier noch nachgebessert
nächster Redner jetzt hier angekündigt
für uns Fraktion Lars Gruber
[Applaus]
denn in meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren seit vielen Monaten Wissen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger das schwierige
Zeiten auf Sie zukommen und dass sie
gerade wenn sie mit kleinen und
mittleren Einkommen ausgestattet sind
vor großen finanziellen
Herausforderungen steht aber die
Bundesregierung blieb aus unserer Sicht
viel zu lange untätig es brauchte
mehrere entlastungspakete um alle
Hilfsbedürftigen Bevölkerungsgruppen zu
erkennen auf der Suche nach vergessenen
Bevölkerungsgruppen verspäte die
Bundesregierung in ihrem Elfenbeinturm
am 4 september die Studierenden und
Rentner durch ihr Fernrohr und kündigte
eine Einmalzahlung über 200 Euro an es
brauchte zwei Monate
bis das Kabinett das beschlossen hat und
es wird zwei Monate dauern bis diese
Regelung in Kraft tritt es wird aber
weitere Monate brauchen bis dieses Geld
auch bei den Betroffenen und Studenten
ankommt weil sie gar keine digitale
Plattform haben
damit wir uns nicht falsch verstehen wir
begrüßen die 200 Euro sehr aber es
fehlte bei den Studis immer irgendwas
erstmal ist die energiepreispauschale
die es nur mit Minijob gibt
Heizkostenzuschuss nur 10%. 9 Euro
Ticket durcheinander bis hin zu den
Mensa Gutscheinen sie haben einfach drei
Monate vertütet
und dann
dann ist das Gesetz auch nicht
vollständig gestern in der
regierungsbefragung kam raus die
Meisterschüler haben sie vergessen
das Gesetz ist also an dieser Stelle
absolut unverständlich wir denken aber
auch dass das Gesetz unnötig ist denn
sie wollen mit diesem Gesetz nur die
Verantwortung an die Länder
transportieren dass wenn das Geld dann
nicht rechtzeitig ankommt sie es den
Ländern in die Schuhe schieben können
deshalb beantragen wir heute hier im
Plenum das endlich Schluss mit dem
verhandeln ist und dass der Bund selbst
die Plattform baut und zwar in den
nächsten 14 Tagen sie aber werden
wahrscheinlich weiter vorstellen sie
werden uns nicht wir werden uns nicht
gegen die Studierenden stellen aber wir
wollen das hier Schluss ist mit diesen
Regelungen mit ihrem Gesetzentwurf
lassen Sie einen leistungsgesetz mit
einer Verordnungsermächtigung zur
späteren Festlegung des konkreten
Verfahrens dieses Vorgehen ist aus
unserer Sicht völlig planlos und
entsperrt jeder föderalen Zusammenarbeit
und auch gestern in der
Regierungserklärung
regierungsbefragung wenig konkret ist
redes wenig abbrechenbares Frau
Ministerin stark Watzinger bei Antworten
auf unsere konkreten Fragen verlieren
sie sich im Ungefähren klein das war
viel wir wollen wir machen wir werden
aber ganz wenig um nicht zu sagen viel
zu wenig wir machen wir tun Frau stark
Watzinger sie bezeichnen ihr Ministerium
selbst als chancenministerium ich möchte
Sie bitten dass sie nicht weiter die
Ministerin der vertanen Chancen sind
vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
von Lars Rover hier noch mal der
spezielle Hinweis den wir auch schon im
Interview festgestellt haben es gibt die
hier noch einen eine gewisse bringe
Pflicht durch die Bundesregierung auch
für alle die die Hilfe für Auszubildende
und Studierende beantragen wollen die
digitale Plattform wirklich arbeitsfähig
zu machen jetzt Andreas medretter für
die SPD-Fraktion wir sind immer noch in
der Krise und trotzdem hat sich das
Konjunkturbarometer des Deutschen
Instituts für Wirtschaftsforschung im
November erholt die Gründe sind so dass
die wie die Sicherstellung der
Gasversorgung und die bisherigen und die
geplanten entlastungspakete der Ampel
unsere Politik wird
das zeigt das Konjunkturbarometer es
zeigt aber auch dass wir noch weit weg
vom Normalzustand sind steigende Preise
labile Lieferketten und die weiterhin
unsichere Lage belasten Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und die Wirtschaft sie brauchen
weiterhin Unterstützung deswegen bringen
wir heute die preisbremsen für Gas Wärme
und Strom in den Bundestag ein weil wir
als Ampel genau für diese Unterstützung
sorgen
meine Damen und Herren es ist zu Beginn
der parlamentarischen Beratungen
hilfreich noch mal ein Schritt
zurückzutreten und sich den
Abschlussbericht der expert in den
Kommission anzuschauen diese Bericht
enthält eben nicht nur einzelne
Maßnahmen er ein enthält ein ökonomisch
ziemlich schlaues Gesamtkonzept das Ziel
sind schnelle Entlastungen und ein
wirksamer Schutz vor Überforderung aber
es geht natürlich auch darum die
Volkswirtschaft und die Preise zu
stabilisieren und es geht darum weitere
Einreise zu setzen es ist schlau dort
anzusetzen wo die Ursache für die
jetzige Situation liegt es sind die
steigenden Gas und Strompreise die die
Inflation ausgelöst haben es sind die
Liquidität der Betriebe und den
Kaufkraft bis in die Mittelschicht
hinein auffressen und genau dagegen
helfen die preisbremsen
es ist auch schlau dass wir die vollen
Anreize zum Einsparen mit dem Bremsen
erhalten wie Kollege janicek gerade
schon gesagt hat richtet sich die
Entlastung nach dem prognostizierten
Verbrauch und ist dementsprechend fix
wer Geld wer Gas und Strom spart spart
sich mit jeder Kilowattstunde bares Geld
und es ist schlau dass wir mit die dass
wir uns das Geld dort wieder zurückholen
wo mit der aktuellen Energiekrise große
Gewinne gemacht werden wir beschließen
morgen übergewinne der Mineralölkonzerne
zu extra zu besteuern und wir schöpfen
unerwartet hohe Erlöse von
Stromerzeugern ab so geht solidarische
Politik in Krisenzeiten meine Damen und
Herren
gerade die erlös-abschöpfung im
Strommarkt ist eine hochkomplexe
Angelegenheit wir greifen damit tief in
den Markt ein aber so zielgerichtet dass
wir keinerlei zusätzlichen Anreiz für
die Verstromung von Gas geben das wollen
wir nicht das müssen wir vermeiden um
Gas einzusparen
gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich noch
wichtige Punkte die wir prüfen müssen
dazu gehört die Frage wie die
Auswirkungen der Abschöpfung am
Strommarkt auf die auf den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energie aus es ist richtig
zumindest einen Teil der Preis Bremsen
aus den übergewinnen der Energieerzeuger
zu finanzieren wir brauchen aber auch
mehr Tempo und Planungssicherheit beim
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren Investitionen in
erneuerbare müssen weiterhin attraktiv
bleiben auch das müssen und werden wir
sicherstellen
meine Damen und Herren um zwei
Prozentpunkte können wir die Inflation
durch die Preisbremse senken sagen
Ökonomen von Deutsche Bank research
genau das brauchen die Menschen und die
Unternehmen in unserem Land ich betone
das auch noch mal ganz bewusst mit Blick
auf Sie meine Damen und Herren von der
Union ihr Fraktionsvorsitzender hat ja
bereits angekündigt die Preisbremse im
Bundesrat aufhalten zu wollen sie wollen
die Entlastungen verzögern auf die die
Menschen dringend warten soll das
verantwortungsvolle Opposition sein ich
glaube nicht wir machen
verantwortungsvolle Regierungsarbeit wir
sorgen mit den Preis Bremsen für die
notwendige Entlastung in dieser
schwierigen Zeit so geht schlaue und
solidarische Politik vielen Dank
die erste Lesung weiterhin der
energiepreisbremsen durch die
Bundesregierung Gesetzentwürfe
eingebracht jetzt gibt es Frömming
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
afd-fraktion Frau Präsidentin Werte
Kollegen also ich finde es ehrlich
gesagt unerträglich wie sich die Ampel
hier heute selbst lobt wofür denn
eigentlich für das herumpfuschen an den
Symptomen einer Krankheit die sie doch
selbst mit ihrer Politik erst
herbeigeführt haben meine Damen und
Herren
und lass mich in diesem Zusammenhang
noch ein Wort sagen zu dem hier ja mit
debattierten Vorschlag eine
energiepauschale für Studenten
auszuzahlen das ist in der Tat auch
notwendig denn mehr als ein Drittel der
Studenten sind armutsgefährdet viele
haben die Temperaturen in ihren
Wohnungen herabgesenkt auf 16 Grad im
Durchschnitt und da finde ich schon
ehrlich gesagt zynisch wenn eine
Abgeordnete der Grünen auf Twitter sich
beklagt dass es hier im Bundestag doch
zu kalt sei und sie müssen einen Schal
anziehen und heißen Tee trinken meine
Damen und Herren wenn einer kein Recht
hat sich über Temperaturen zu beklagen
dann sind das die Grünen
vielleicht auch noch ein Wort zu den
Anträgen der Union also liebe Kollegen
das ist ja schon ein kleines Kuckucksei
was sie hier der Ampel ins Nest legen
wollen sie schlagen vor dass das
Bundesministerium und jetzt weniger die
Länder dafür zuständig sein sollten die
200 Euro möglichst schnell auszuzahlen
glauben Sie das eigentlich im Ernst dass
das das Bundesministerium hinbekommt in
der notwendigen Zeit ich erinnere nur
mal daran wie lange wir auf den
digitalpakt gewartet haben 2019
beschlossen und immer noch warten viele
Schulen darauf dass die simpelsten
Einrichtungen wie ein Breitbandanschluss
oder funktionierende Laptops ankommen
auch da schon hat der Bund versagt der
Bund versagt in zentralen Dingen deshalb
wäre es wesentlich besser und
zielführender sie würden für eine
vernünftige Politik sorgen die Energie
bezahlbar macht und überlassen ansonsten
denen etwas die was davon verstehen
nämlich den Ländern vor Ort die können
die Probleme an den Schulen selbst dann
viel besser beheben ich danke Ihnen
meine Damen und Herren
tatsächlich wir erwarten wir jetzt die
erste ministeräußerung in dieser Debatte
es war schon von ihr die Rede dass sie
ihre Chancen besser nutzen soll Bettina
stark Watzinger die Bundesministerin für
Bildung und Forschung
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier geht es
heute um mehr als ein Grad Celsius in
Räumen hier geht es heute mehr als auch
nur um das Geld wir schützen heute
unsere Zukunftschancen davon haben wir
zusammen gekämpft und zwar erfolgreich
dafür dass Forschung und Wissenschaft
einbezogen sind bei den Entlastungen
dass die gut durch die Energiekrise
kommen nehmen wir die
Teilchenbeschleuniger an den
helmholtzinstituten die strahlzeiten ist
ein Monate voraus ausgebucht ohne trieb
ohne Strom aber keinen Betrieb keine
Forschung und im Worst Case bleiben
hunderte qualifizierungsarbeiten auf der
Strecke tausende Erkenntnisse oder in
einer Biobank wenn die
abluftfiltersysteme bei den
Krankheitserregern nicht mehr betrieben
werden können
jahrelange Arbeit umsonst wir setzen uns
heute für Wissenschaft und Forschung ein
damit wir morgen überhaupt noch die
Basis für Wissenschaft Forschung haben
meine Damen und Herren
und wir entlasten dreifach alle
wissenschaftlichen Einrichtungen egal
wie groß erhalten die Dezember
Soforthilfe außerdem greift die
gasenstrombremse für Kitas Schulen
Hochschulen und die großen
Forschungseinrichtungen und ein
härtefallfond bringt die
energieintensive Forschung durch die
Krise die großen Anlagen die viel Strom
brauchen vom Teilchenbeschleuniger bis
zum höchstleistungsrechner damit ist die
außeruniversitäre Forschung abgedeckt
Dank
härtefall-intervention haben unsere
Reaktionsfähigkeit auf Krisen der
Klimawandel macht ja keine Pause nur
weil wir gerade ein Energieproblem haben
unsere Wettbewerber halten nicht inne
nur weil unsere Versorgung mit Gas und
Öl wie sie neue Regeln müssen wenn wir
weiter gut leben wollen dann müssen
Wissenschaft und Forschung
weiterarbeiten können auch in der Krise
meine Damen und Herren
mit
bis zu 2 Milliarden Euro unterstützen
wir die Bildungs- und
Forschungseinrichtungen damit leistet
der Bund einen großen Beitrag in
schwierigen Zeiten fakt ist allerdings
auch die Länder stehen für skalisch
besser da als der Bund es ist also recht
und billig wenn sich auch die Länder an
den Mehrkosten ihrer Hochschulen
beteiligen der Bund sieht sich klar als
Anwalt von Wissenschaft und Forschung
und dazu gehört das Werben um starke
Allianzen denn nur erfolgreich sind wir
wenn wir gemeinsam arbeiten das gilt
auch für die Entlastung der Studierenden
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler die 200
europaschale die Zahl der Bund aber die
Auszahlung der brauchen wir die Länder
wir haben geprüft gibt es einen
zentralen Weg wie das Geld auf die
Konten kommt Familienkassen
Krankenkassen Finanzämter funktioniert
nicht KfW geht auch nicht wir reden über
7,5 Millionen Studierende und
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler an
tausenden Hochschulen und Schulen wer wo
eingeschrieben ist das wissen nur die
Länder dort ist es bekannt für die 200
euro-pauschale wird es eine zentrale
Online-Plattform geben für einen
möglichst schlankes Verfahren der Bund
bezahlt die Plattform Sachsen-Anhalt
unsere Länder auf der unser Partner auf
der Länderseite hat die Weichen schon
gestellt wir haben den Zug aufs Gleis
gesetzt wir handeln nach der Devise
der Bund macht
der Bund macht alles was möglich ist die
Länder kommen dazu wo es nötig ist und
ich gehe auch davon aus dass die Länder
ein Interesse daran haben die jungen
Menschen zu entlasten und liebe Freunde
von der Union liebe Frau Ludwig mir ist
noch ein Einsatz von ihnen aus der
letzten Debatte im Ohr geblieben sie
haben gesagt ich zitiere Ministerium im
Tiefschlaf wenn sie mich angreifen in
Ordnung wir sind politische Akteurinnen
wir sind im Wettstreit aber wenn sie
Vorurteile gegen Beamte und Angestellte
im Ministerium schüren dann ist das
billig sie haben 16 Jahren dieses
Ministerium geführt
sie kennen die Menschen die dort
arbeiten unter Hochdruck alles geben für
gute Bildung in unserem Land für gute
Forschung und ihr Parteivorsitzender hat
vor kurzem sich über die politischen
Stil in der Auseinandersetzung beschwert
ich würde mal sagen bitte nehmen Sie
sich das zu Herzen das geht auch anders
wir haben
wir haben zusammen
Energiekrise der 200 Euro pauschale
liegen die dreifache Entlastung der
Bafög-Empfänger voraus durch die
bafög-reform heizkostenzuschlag 1
heizkostenzuschlag zwei eine dreifache
Entlastung die es jetzt auch vorgesehen
für die wissenschaftlichen Einrichtung
für die Zukunft unseres Landes denn
Wissenschaft löst jeden Tag ein neues
Rätsel wir brauchen sie vielen Dank
bevor ich die nächste Rednerin Aufrufe
hat das Wort zu einer Kurzintervention
der Kollege ja zombeck aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Frau
Bundesministerin sie haben sich gerade
beklagt wir hätten ihr Haus als im
Tiefschlaf befindend bezeichnet das
Frauenministerin bezieht sich nur auf
die Führungsebene und darauf dass wir
hören das ganz viele Beamten und Beamten
nicht durchdringen mit ihren mit ihren
Anliegen die Kurzintervention deshalb
weil sie vorhin ausgeführt haben es geht
bei diesem härtefallfonds zudem wir sie
übrigens getrieben haben durch eine
Bundestagsdebatte am Tag der Debatte
unseres Antrags haben sie den
härtefallfond angekündigt sie wussten zu
dem Zeitpunkt aber nicht mehr wie groß
er ist oder für wen er gilt jetzt wissen
wir es er gilt nur für die
außeruniversitären
Forschungseinrichtungen und sie haben
vorhin von Teilchenbeschleuniger von
Rechenzentren von all diesen Dingen
gesprochen gestern in der Anhörung im
Bildungsausschuss hat Professor Wörner
für die TU Darmstadt da gelegt das genau
diese Einrichtung an dieser Uni da sind
und die Hochschulen sind ausgeschlossen
ich frage Sie an dieser Stelle warum
haben sie die Hochschulen ausgenommen
die TU9 die Technischen Universitäten
wären alle mal notwendig mit
berücksichtigt zu werden ist im
härtefallfonds der jedenfalls nach all
dem was hier gerade korportiert wird
ausschließlich für die universitären
Forschungseinrichtungen gilt
Frau Ministerin
Herr Kollege jazzombeck ich empfehle
Ihnen das Lesen unseres Grundgesetzes
und dem Aufbau der föderalen Struktur
die Hochschulen sind in der
Verantwortung der Länder wir entziehen
uns dieser Verantwortung aber in keiner
Weise
zukunftsvertragsstudium und Lehre
Professorinnen Programm und viele
gemeinsame Programme und jetzt die zwei
Milliarden für die
energiepreisbremsen der Bund steht da
und wir arbeiten mit den Ländern
zusammen
soweit sozusagen der kurze Austausch
zwischen Thomas jazzomberg im Sprecher
für Bildung und Forschung der
Unionsfraktion und der Bundesministerin
für Bildung und Forschung Bettina stark
Wertinger hier noch einmal um die Frage
der Einbeziehung von Institutionen in
den härtefallfondsliste Rednerin Nina
Star für die bündnisgrüne Fraktion
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin lieber Herr Minister Frau
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen liebe Gäste
es ist gut dass wir heute die Strom- und
gaspreisbremsen auf den Weg bringen und
damit unmittelbar spürbare Entlastung
für jeden Privathaushalt schaffen ich
möchte aber jetzt auch noch mal weil es
nicht nur für die private Haushalte gilt
den Blick lenken wie die Ministerin das
auch schon getan hat auf die
Bildungswissenschaft und
Forschungseinrichtungen ganz herzlichen
Dank auch annenminister Habeck und das
ganze Team des bmwk das bei diesem Paket
Bildung und Forschung von Anfang an
mitgedacht wurde
Bildung und Forschung sind so elementar
wichtig für unsere Gesellschaft sie
dürfen nicht noch einmal in einer Krise
hinten runterfallen und es ist gut dass
wir als Ampel in dieser Krise dafür
Sorge tragen
zusätzlich
zusätzlich zu dem Preis Bremsen
unterstützen wir außeruniversitäre
Forschungseinrichtungen die besonders
energieintensive Forschung betreiben mit
dem Herrn voll von mit bis zu 500
Millionen Euro und das BMBF arbeitet da
mit Hochdruck an der Umsetzung
herzlichen Dank auch dafür und natürlich
weil sie sich Sorgen um die Hochschule
machen leisten auch die Länder einen
Beitrag und ich freue mich als
Berlinerin ganz besonders dass Berlin
beispielsweise 180 Millionen Euro
energiehilfen unter anderem zur
Verfügung stellt für die Hochschulen
weitere 13 Millionen sind für das
Studierendenwerk reserviert im
Nachtragshaushalt und herzlichen Dank
dafür an die zuständigen Kollegen in
Berlin
wir entlasten aber nicht nur die
Bildungsinstitutionen wir unterstützen
auch Studierende Auszubildende und
Schüler in ganz direkt heute werden wir
nämlich auch die 200 Euro Einmalzahlung
für alle Studierenden beschließen im
parlamentarischen Verfahren haben wir
durchgesetzt dass das auch für
promotionsstudierende gilt und es ist
auch gut dass alle ausländischen
Studierenden die hier wohnen diese 200 €
bekommen und ausnahmsweise haben sie ja
mal
was 100 € fangen nicht die gesamten
Kosten auf sondern wir haben deshalb
zusätzlich ein ganzes Paket an Maßnahmen
auf den Weg gebracht zwei
Heizkostenzuschüsse
energiepreispauschale Kindergeld
Erhöhung massive Ausweitung des
bafögsbezugs und vieles mehr damit
unterstützen wir Studierende Fachschule
in Auszubildende und wir denken auch an
unsere Bildungs- und
Forschungseinrichtung und machen damit
Deutschland zukunftsfest herzlichen Dank
kurze Redebeitrag von Nina Star von den
Bündnis Grünen ist folgt für die
Unionsfraktion Thomas Gebhardt er ist
Obmann im Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und
Energie
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren viele Menschen in
unserem Land machen sich in diesen Tagen
sorgen bei einer täglich werde ich von
Bürgern gefragt wie können wir noch
unsere Rechnungen für Strom und Gas und
Öl und Holz bezahlen und Unternehmen
schildern wir die hohen Preise Gefährten
massiv ihre Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und
tatsächlich stehen einige vor dem Aus in
dieser Situation muss der Staat
finanziell unterstützen das ist denke
ich keine Frage wir sind uns hier im
Deutschen Bundestag in dieser Frage auch
grundsätzlich einig dass wir Menschen
und Unternehmen schnell unter die Arme
greifen das haben wir seit Wochen und
Zeit Monaten aber was ist geschehen es
gab ein Hot in der Bundesregierung bis
in den September hinein haben sie
zunächst an dieser gescheiterten
gasumlage geklammert und sich dann erst
auf den Weg gemacht hin zu einer
energiepreisbremse und bei dieser
Vorgeschichte ist es ja kein Wunder dass
diese energiepreisbremse auf den
allerletzten Drücker kommt und sie ist
unausgegoren ich will es an drei Punkten
deutlich machen der erste Punkt die
Vorschläge der Bundesregierung sie sind
viel zu bürokratisch die Fachleute sagen
uns in Teilen gar nicht verständlich
nicht umsetzbar und mich würde es nicht
wundern wenn wir in den nächsten Wochen
in der Umsetzung dieser gaspreisbremse
und strompreisbremse ein Chaos erleben
würden der zweite Punkt die Preisbremse
ist ungerecht sie ist ungerecht weil sie
vergessen die Millionen von Menschen die
mit Öl oder mit Holz heizen müssen auch
diese erleben enorme Preissteigerungen
aber die Bundesregierung gibt darauf
überhaupt gar keine Antwort sie reden
nur über Gas und das ist nicht in
Ordnung und das ist ein Schlag ins
Gesicht des ländlichen Raums wo
besonders viele zum Heizen auf Öl und
Holz angewiesen sind
und meine Damen und Herren sie wollen
bei den erneuerbaren Energien abschöpfen
wir wollen doch das Deutschland und in
Deutschland mehr investiert wird in
erneuerbare Energien aber sie riskieren
mit ihrem Vorschlag genau das Gegenteil
das weniger investiert wird und wenn sie
das so umsetzen dann wird auch ihr aus
ihrer Preisbremse in Wahrheit eine
Investitionsbremse und das ist das
Letzte was Deutschland im Moment
gebrauchen kann und bei der Bioenergie
hat alleine die Ankündigung des Gesetzes
Schaden angerichtet sie würden die
Bioenergie ab das ist fatal ist doch die
Bioenergie eine verlässliche eine
regelbare und eine heimische Energieform
die wir brauchen meine Damen und Herren
an die Bundesregierung verstärken sie
nicht noch weiter die ohne hin
bestehende Energie Knappheit Deutschland
macht jetzt
sehr sehr viele Schulden um für ein
gutes Jahr die hohen Preise teilweise
abzufedern aber ich frage was kommt
eigentlich danach wir ermöglichen wir
das Unternehmen auch über diese Zeit
hinaus wettbewerbsfähig bleiben wie
ermöglichen wir das die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in diesem Land auch über diese
Zeit hinaus ihre Strom und Gas und
holzrechnung bezahlen können meine Damen
und Herren hohe Preise sind immer
Ausdruck von Knappheit Energie ist knapp
und deswegen ist es doch jetzt das Gebot
der Stunde dass wir alles dafür tun dass
Angebot zu erhöhen wir müssen
investieren und wir müssen für die
notwendige Infrastruktur Sorgen ich will
nur einen Punkt nennen wir müssen jetzt
Vollgas geben bei der
Wasserstofftechnologie wir brauchen doch
auch dann verlässlich Energie Mensch
Wind und Sonne nicht zur Verfügung
stehenden
nachdrücklicher nach dem Wegfall des
russischen Gases gilt wir haben hier
überhaupt keine Zeit zu verlieren und
ich kann nicht verstehen dass sie
Bundesregierung jetzt in diesen Tagen
gerade ihr Konzept zur
wasserstoffnetzentwicklung um ein ganzes
Jahr verschoben hat das können wir uns
nicht leisten machen Sie dieses Konzept
sorgen Sie dafür dass Deutschland
schnell wasserstoffland Nummer eins wird
weiterhin die erste Lesung in den
energiepreisbremsen zwei Gesetzentwürfe
durch die Bundesregierung und bereits
die Abstimmung für die Unterstützung für
junge Menschen in Ausbildung nächster
Redner Sebastian Roloff SPD-Fraktion
Pferde frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir diskutieren
heute nichts weniger als eine der
größten Entlastungen für Bürgerinnen und
Bürger seit Bestehen der Bundesrepublik
bin sehr froh dass die Ampel
Handlungsfähigkeit bewiesen hat und wir
dieses Finanzvolumen von 200 Milliarden
heute auf den Weg bringen es ist wichtig
dass wir es möglichst schnell in
sinnvolle wirksame und natürlich
möglichst zielgenauer wurde es aus
technischen Gründen möglich ist
Konzepte gießen und dementsprechend
haben wir heute mit diesen Beratungen in
großen Fortschritt gemacht aber auch die
ersten drei entlastungspakete der Ampel
waren weitreichende Unterstützungen
allen voran zum Beispiel der dezember-
wichtige Überbrückungshilfe ist die auch
viele Sorgen von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
auf der einen und von Unternehmen auf
der anderen Seite
ernst nimmt und heute
heute sprechen wir über das noch größere
Paket die gaspreisbremse wird zusammen
mit den unterschiedlich konzipierten
härtefallfonds bis ins Jahr 2024 hinein
Sicherheit geben niemand wird in
Deutschland frieren müssen weil die
Rechnung nicht mehr bezahlbar ist und
das muss unser gemeinsames Anliegen sein
natürlich ist klar dass diese Bremse
teuer ist aber nicht zu handeln wäre
noch teurer es gäbe ganz gravierende
Verwerfungen die Industrialisierung
Arbeitsplatzverluste und dementsprechend
ist es wichtig jetzt hier staatlich
Regeln einzugreifen klar ist aber auch
und das haben wir bei der Konzeption
bedacht dass wir natürlich auch
Sparanreize schaffen müssen und das ist
in dem Konzept vorgesehen ich freue mich
ganz besonders weil ich es mir auch fast
ein bisschen gewünscht habe als ich das
letzte Mal hier an der Stelle stand dass
wir eine rückwirkende Entlastung ab
Januar hinbekommen das hat in den
Gesprächen Gott sei Dank funktioniert
und auch das ist genau das richtige
Signal an die Unternehmen in diesem Land
es ist jetzt richtig dass Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und Unternehmen konkret
planen können wann kommt welche
Belastung wann kommen welche
preisbremsen wann können wir kalkulieren
und es ist unsere Aufgabe als Politik
ergänzen zu gucken dass wir auch die
Liquidität von Unternehmen sicherstellen
weil auch wenn es rückwirkend gilt bis
März natürlich auch ein gewisser
Zeitraum zu überbrücken ist darüber
hinaus ist die gaspreisbremse auch
volkswirtschaftlich richtig wir haben es
heute schon gehört sie wird inflations
dämpfend wirken und es wird eine
spürbare Entlastung auch diesbezüglich
sein und dementsprechend ist das genau
der richtige Weg den wir gehen zum
Abschluss darf ich noch mal ganz
ausdrücklich auch seitens der
SPD-Fraktion feststellen dass wir diese
Diskussionen über einen gesundschrumpfen
der Industrie oder der deutschen
Wirtschaft etwas fehlgeleitet finden wir
stehen an der Seite der Beschäftigten
und es geht nicht um den
Industrialisierung es geht um
Transformation und hier braucht es
mutige Schritte
wir werden die Weichen so stellen dass
wir langfristig erfolgreich sind
konkurrenzfähiger industriestrompreis
ebenso wie eine Reform des Marit
order-prinzips und natürlich auch den
Aufbau der erneuerbaren Energien ich
darf zum Abschluss sagen bin
außerordentlich stolz dass wir diese
Gesetze heute auf den Weg bringen vielen
Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion DR
Andreas Lenz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sehen uns
mit der Ampel einig dass wir
Entlastungen brauchen wir das Wasser
aber dann auch schon mit der Einigkeit
die Entlassungen kommen zu spät sie sind
zu bürokratisch und sie sind auch noch
ungerecht unsere Vorschläge liegen seit
Anfang des Jahres auf dem Tisch sie
haben es versäumt im Sommer über ein
tagfähiges Konzept zu entwickeln und
stattdessen lieber um die gasumlage
gestritten die nicht nur Unsinn sondern
auch
verfassungswidrig gewesen wäre und sie
machen gleich weiter zuerst wollen sie
die von Ihnen als Zufalls Gewinne
titulierten Erträge aus Erneuerbaren
rückwirkend bis März abschöpfen
verfassungsrechtlich auch zweifelhaft
dann ab September jetzt ab Dezember das
schafft kein Klima für Investitionen in
der erneuerbare das Gegenteil wird damit
erzeugt sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
ein grün ein grün geführtes Ministerium
verunsichert beim Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren das muss man sich erst
einmal vorstellen meine Damen und Herren
bei den Preis Bremsen schaffen sie neue
bürokratische Monster die vorliegenden
Vorschläge sind so nicht verständlich
und daher nicht umsetzbar das sagt nicht
ich das sagt Frau Andrea von Bibi die
sehr gut kennen müssten und zwar sagt
sie das noch letzte und diese Woche
schaffen sie endlich Klarheit und
Umsetzbarkeit meine Damen und Herren
Biogas biogasmus anders die handelt
werden als PV und Wind hier wurde oft
genau das gemacht was wir brauchen und
was wir wollen hier wurde flexibilisiert
hier wurde investiert um für das
Gesamtsystem entsprechend bei den
nachfrage-system dienlich zu sein
diejenigen die hier investiert haben
dürfen nicht dafür bestraft werden meine
Damen und Herren und dafür stehen wir
als Union die Ampel will sogenannte
zufallsgewinne bei Biogas PV und Wind
abschöpfen bei Steinkohlekraftwerken
aber nicht weil die laut Ministerium
notwendig sind um Erdgas beim verstromen
zu sparen Kernkraftwerke zur
Stromerzeugung will man aber stilllegen
so kann man das Zusammenfassen ihre
Energiepolitik passt doch hinten und
vorne nicht zusammen meine Damen und
Herren
sie haben immer noch keine hinreichende
Lösung wie sie Bürger mit Holzpellet mit
Holz mit Heizöl Heizungen entlasten
wollen auch hier brauchen wir
entsprechende Lösungen und nicht den
Gang zum Jobcenter natürlich 200
Milliarden Euro das ist ein wuchtiges
Paket wir müssen aber schon auch
berücksichtigen das Geld wird nicht
investiert es wird nichts gebaut es wird
nichts modernisiert es wird nicht
erneuert es wird lediglich konsultiert
da ist ja die Ampel auch entsprechend
spezialisiert in den USA wird
gleichzeitig ein sogenannter in Flächen
reduction Act ins Leben gerufen mit
einem Volumen von fast 500 Millionen
Milliarden Dollar und dort wird
investiert und wir müssen in Deutschland
auch wieder investieren ist rot nichts
weniger als die die Industrialisierung
des Landes wir müssen alles aber auch
wirklich alles daran setzen dass wir in
Deutschland und Europa auch zukünftig
wettbewerbsfähig sind dass der Mittel
produzierende Gewerbe dass die Industrie
auch hier Perspektiven haben die
Chemieindustrie erwartet mehr oder
weniger unbeachtet von der
Öffentlichkeit
2022 einen Produktionsrückgang von 8,5
Prozent und durch die 70% Grenze bei der
gaspreisbremse werden Anreize gesetzt
weniger Gas zu verbrauchen das stimmt
aber eben auch weniger Anreize oder es
werden auch Anreize gesetzt weniger zu
produzieren wenn du wenn die Industrie
aber weg ist dann gibt es auch nichts
mehr zu transformieren dann gibt es eben
auch keine keinen Weg hin zur
CO2-Neutralität und keine Arbeitsplätze
in Deutschland wir brauchen also einen
Mittelstand wir brauchen einen
Industriestrom Tarif wir brauchen CO2
neutrale Geschäftsmodelle und keine
Überregulierung und wir brauchen
insgesamt mehr Perspektiven für den
Wirtschaftsstandort und führt auch für
den Industriestandort Deutschland
herzlichen Dank
eine der Fragen die im Raum stehen
reichen die avisierten bremsen um auch
kleine und mittlere Unternehmen in
dieser energiepreiskrise zu retten und
am Leben zu halten diese Frage wird sich
später beantworten für die SPD-Fraktion
jetzt Lina Seidel
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren Herr Kollege jazzomeck ich
möchte dann doch noch mal daran erinnern
dass in der gestrigen Anhörung im
Ausschuss für Bildung und Forschung alle
Sachverständigen und zwar von
Hochschulrektorenkonferenz bis zu den
außeruniversitären
Forschungseinrichtungen gesagt haben
dass sie sehr profitieren von den
Maßnahmen die die Bundesregierung in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten in Kraft
gesetzt hat und natürlich auch von den
energiepreisbremsen über die wir hier
gerade sprechen
der Deutsche Ethikrat hat von paar Tagen
eine AD hoc-empfehlung zum besseren
Schutz der jungen Generation
veröffentlicht er geht darin auch die
psychischen Belastung ein mit denen
Kinder Jugendliche und junge Erwachsene
in den letzten knapp drei Jahren umgehen
mussten und ich will mit Erlaubnis der
Präsidentin gerne dessen Vorsitzenden
der dessen Vorsitzende Alena Burgs
zitieren die gesagt hat wir schulden als
Gesellschaft Kindern Jugendlichen und
jungen Erwachsenen nicht nur Dank und
Respekt sondern konkretes Handeln die
Zeit der corona-pandemie wurde von
jungen Menschen als große emotional in
vielen Fällen auch existenzielle Krise
wahrgenommen und was sie in eine nicht
zuvor gekannte Belastungssituation dann
kam der völkerrechtswidrige
Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die Ukraine
und die damit verbundenen
Preissteigerungen die zum Beispiel für
Studierende die gerade von zu Hause
ausgezogen sind und so sowieso wenig
Geld in der Tasche haben besonders zu
spüren sind und über all dem liegt
natürlich auch die Sorge von dem
Klimawandel dessen Auswirkungen insbes
wäre die junge Generation zu spüren
bekommen wird wenn wir ihn nicht in den
Krieg Griff bekommen und diese
Überlagerung von Ausnahmezuständen für
junge Menschen darf nicht übersehen
werden sie haben sich in den letzten
Jahren solidarisch gezeigt und
Einschränkungen hingenommen und deshalb
schulden wir dieser Generation als
Gesellschaft Solidarität und
Unterstützung und für uns als politik
bedeutet das dann eben auch neben Worten
der Anerkennung Taten folgen zu lassen
wie von Alena Burg fordert und deshalb
bin ich wirklich sehr froh dass wir
heute den Gesetzesentwurf zur Energie-
und damit und damit ist es ja nicht
getan ich habe das hier immer wieder
betont und die Ministerin Frau stark
Watzinger hat es gerade auch noch mal
aufgeführt wir haben ja bereits eine
Kette von Maßnahmen verabschiedet die
erhöhungeröffnung des BAföG die
Verankerung des nothilfe-mechanismus
Anhebung Mindestlohn Minijob Grenze und
so weiter und so fort und natürlich
profitiert diese Gruppe von Menschen
auch von den energiepreisbremsen über
die wir ja gerade auch beraten und die
wir dann im Dezember verabschieden
werden und Sie sehen das ist ein
bemerkenswertes Paket an Maßnahmen die
wir hier in den letzten Monaten
beschlossen haben aber die besten
Beschlüsse nutzen natürlich nichts wenn
sie dann erst sehr spät ankommen wir
haben hier parlamentarisch jetzt den Weg
frei gemacht für eine schnelle
Auszahlung der 200 Euro und jetzt liegt
das an Bundesministerium und auch an den
Ländern die tatsächliche Zahlungen dann
zügig vorauszugehen ich möchte zum
Schluss noch mal ähm eindringlich dafür
werden dass auch in dieser Energiekrise
Schulen und Hochschulen unbedingt offen
bleiben müssen damit steigende Kosten
eben nicht noch weiter an diese Gruppe
abgeschoben werden und damit nach fast
drei Jahren der pandemiebedingten
Einschränkungen der Austausch und die
Begegnung junger Menschen gefördert
statt beschränkt werden kann vielen Dank
wir gehen langsam in die Schlusskurve in
diesem
Tagesordnungspunkt 7 über die
energiepreisbremse und die Studierenden
energiepauschale so wie es hier benannt
ist von der Tagungsleitung die letzte
Rednerin Jessica Rosenthal SPD die
Juso-Vorsitzende in ihrem Leben
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir diskutieren
heute in erster Lesung die Gas- und
strompreisbremse und bringen damit wie
auch schon vielfach unterstrichen
wichtige Entlastungen auf den Weg denn
gerade einkommensschwache Haushalte
trifft diese Krise besonders hart die
einkommensschwächsten 20 Prozent wenden
62% ihres Konsums für Nahrungsmittel
wohnen und Energie auf das bedeutet dass
sie bis zu fünf Mal so stark belastet
sind in dieser Krise als alle anderen
und gerade deshalb ist es auch so
wichtig dass wir heute und hier und
jetzt in zweiter und dritter Lesung die
energiepreispauschale für Studierende
und Fachschülerinnen beraten
denn wer sind denn die
einkommensschwachen Gruppen es sind
Studierende und Azubis Azubis haben oft
ein sehr kleines Einkommen sie müssen
diese Kosten für eine eigene Wohnung
aufwenden für Lebensmittel davon auch
noch die Energiepreise Bezahlen im
ersten Lehrjahr verdient ein eine
Friseur eine
Auszubildende im Friseurhandwerk 585
Euro eine im Fleischerei Handwerk sind
es dann schon 736 aber mal ehrlich wer
soll in dieser Zeit davon leben können
und deshalb ist es gut und richtig dass
wir mit der Reform des Bafögs eben auch
die Berufsausbildungsbeihilfe reformiert
haben dass da mehr ankommt für
Auszubildende dass wir den
Heizkostenzuschuss auf den Weg gebracht
haben dass wir jetzt auch mit dem
Programm jungen wohnen was auf den Weg
bringen um das Wohnen bezahlbar zu
machen und dass wir die 300 € auch für
Studierende auf den Weg gebracht haben
aber von die auch für auszubilden auf
den Weg gebracht haben von diesen 300
Euro haben eben nicht alle
Auszubildenden profitiert gerade die die
im schulischen Bereich eine Ausbildung
machen und das sind viele junge Menschen
in diesem Land die haben nicht
profitiert wir reden dabei von den
erziehungs- und Gesundheitsberufen wir
reden dabei von notfallsanitäterin
Gesundheits- und Krankenpflegerin von
Heilerziehungspflegerin von
Erzieherinnen das sind doch die Berufe
die gerade in der corona-pandemie für
uns alle so viel gestemmt haben und
deshalb müssen jetzt
gerade diese Ausbildungsberufe auch die
200 Euro bekommen das ist eine Frage des
Respekts und genau deshalb bringen wir
das jetzt auf den Weg 200 Euro auch für
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler das
muss kommen bitte stimmen Sie zu vielen
Dank
ja soweit Jessica Rosenthal von der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion sie ist die
letzte Rednerin gewesen hier in dieser
Debatte um die Energiepreis Bremse und
die Studierenden energiepauschale Top 7
vielleicht sie haben es sicher bemerkt
an ihrem Revert das ist nicht die erste
Rednerin gewesen mit der roten Schleife
warum 1988 hat die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation den ersten
Dezember zum Welt AIDS Tag ausgerufen
und das ist das Zeichen heute dafür wir
gehen jetzt in die Abstimmung für die
Studierenden energiepauschale
für Studierende Fachschülerinnen und
Fachschüler sowie berufsfachschülerin
und Berufsfachschüler in Bildungsgängen
mit dem Ziel eines mindestens
zweijährigen berufsqualifizierenden
Abschluss ist der Ausschuss für Bildung
und Forschung und
Technikfolgenabschätzung empfiehlt in
seiner Beschlussempfehlung auf
Drucksache
4.741 den Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion der
SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP auf
Drucksache
4.536 anzunehmen hierzu liegt ein
Änderungsantrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu
auf Drucksache
4.744 vor über denen wir zuerst
abstimmen wer stimmt für diesen
Änderungsantrag das ist die Fraktion der
cdu/csu wer stimmt dagegen
das sind die Fraktionen die Linke SPD
mindestens 90 die Grünen die FDP wer
enthält sich das ist die afd-fraktion
damit ist der Änderungsantrag abgelehnt
ich bitte nun diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion der SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen FDP auf Drucksache
4.536 zustimmen wollen um das
Handzeichen
das sind die Fraktionen die Linke SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen FDP
cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
niemand
Enthaltungen die afd-fraktion damit ist
der Gesetzentwurf
in zweiter Beratung angenommen dritte
Beratung und Schlussabstimmung ich bitte
diejenigen die dem Gesetzentwurf
zustimmen wollen sich zu erheben
das sind die die Fraktionen die Linke
SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen FDP
cdu/csu-fraktion Enthaltungen
ja ich mache es mir jetzt einfacher
Enthaltung die afd-fraktion Gegenstimmen
niemand
der Gesetzentwurf ist damit angenommen
jetzt braucht es nur noch diese digitale
Plattform und dann kann das Geld auch
fließen aber da müssen noch viele Hände
mitmachen Antrag der Fraktion der
cdu/csu auf Drucksache
4.677 mit dem Titel
200 Euro Einmalzahlung jetzt an Studie
Studenten und Studenten sowie
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler
auszahlen wer stimmt für diesen Antrag
das ist die cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt
dagegen das ist sind die
Fraktionen die Linke SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen FDP und Enthaltungen die
afd-fraktion damit ist der Antrag
abgelehnt
ich rufe nun auf den Zusatzpunkt 3
Beratung des Antrags der Fraktion der
cdu/csu mit dem Titel keine
erbschaftssteuererhöhung durch die
Hintertür
für die Aussprache
wurde eine Dauer von 68 Minuten
vereinbart
die Bundestagspräsidentin Bärbel Baas
ruft jetzt diesen Zusatzpunkt 3 auf
Stichwort Erbschaftssteuer es gibt ein
Jahressteuergesetz 2022 das wurde am 14
Oktober hier in diesem Haus zum ersten
Mal debattiert es enthält einige Punkte
die noch einmal im Nachgang
diskussionswürdig waren und auch ein
bisschen durch die Medien gegen nämlich
die Art und Weise auch die bestimmte
Freibeträge definiert wurden das Ganze
also jetzt noch mal auf Antrag der
Unionsfraktion hier in der Debatte wir
haben einen gewissen Wechsel der
Fachpolitiker
von Energie und Wirtschaftsbereich hin
zu den Finanz- und Haushaltspolitikern
und jetzt das erste Wort an die
Unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
den Antrag eingebracht hat
frau Präsidentin werde Kolleginnen und
Kollegen mit unserem Antrag keine
erbschaftssteuererhöhung durch die
Hintertür wollen wir sicherstellen dass
auch zukünftig eine vernünftige Balance
bei der Erbschaft und Schenkungssteuer
vorhanden ist denn mit der im
Jahressteuergesetz der Ampel
vorgesehenen Veränderung beim
Bewertungsgesetz stehen wir vor einer
empfindlichen Erhöhung bei der Erbschaft
und Schenkungssteuer bei Wohnungen
Häusern und Grundstücke
die steuerliche Neubewertung wird dazu
führen dass die seit 2009 unverändert
gebliebenen Freibeträge bei der
erbschafts-
eine gerechte Erbschaftssteuer ist in
einer sozialen Marktwirtschaft ein ganz
wesentlicher Faktor und dabei ist es von
großer Bedeutung dass wir hier Maß und
Mitte halten und nicht umsonst ist ja im
Grundgesetz in Artikel 14 nicht nur das
Eigentum garantiert sondern auch die
Vermögensnachfolge auch der
generationentransfer über das Erbrecht
und die Möglichkeit
die Möglichkeit bereits voll
versteuertes Vermögen
innerhalb einer Familie auf die nächste
Generation übertragen zu können ist ein
ganz wesentlicher Treibstoff in unserer
sozialen Marktwirtschaft das treibt die
soziale Marktwirtschaft an denn wer baut
als privater ein Haus wenn er später das
gleiche nicht in der Familie weitergeben
kann
wir brauchen also eine
Erbschaft und Schenkungssteuer die
Leistung nicht erstickt wir peppeln den
Wohnungsbau mit viel Steuergeld in
vielen Bereichen weil wir zusätzlichen
Wohnraum brauchen und wenn dann die
Erben wegen überhöhter Besteuerung zum
Verkauf des erschaffenen Wohnraums
benötigt werden dann stimmt doch
irgendetwas nicht das muss man doch mal
insgesamt sehen auch das ist
Nachhaltigkeit wenn wir Menschen die
Möglichkeit nehmen das teilweise über
Generationen hinweg aufgebaute
erschaffene auf die nächste Generation
zu übertragen dann nehmen wir Anreize
für wirtschaftliche Betätigung in einer
sozialen Marktwirtschaft muss sich
Leistung lohnen und wenn der Staat den
Menschen so viel weg besteuert dann
erstickt er die Leistungsbereitschaft
dann erstickt er den Leistungswillen der
Menschen und das gilt bei Ertragsteuern
genauso wie bei der Erbschaft was er
eine substanzsteuer ist
viele Menschen arbeiten sie sparen sie
gründen sie erhalten Vermögen gerade um
es später ihren Kindern weiter zu
übergeben und ich glaube wir werden in
dieser Debatte ja noch einiges hören und
da weiß ich jetzt schon da wird nachher
wieder die mehr vom Erbe als
leistungsloses Einkommen können
diese mehr ist in den meisten Fällen
falsch unser Steuerrecht beruht auf dem
Grundsatz der Besteuerung nach der
individuellen Leistungsfähigkeit und die
Weitergabe von bereits versteuerten
Vermögen innerhalb einer Familie
verändert die wirtschaftliche
Leistungsfähigkeit dieser Familie
überhaupt nicht
die Weitergabe von aufgebauten
Vermögenswerten an die nächste
Generation ist kein leistungsloses
Einkommen es ist in dieser Familie kein
windfall Profit denn man weg besteuern
müsste sondern es ist Erhaltung von
leistungsanreizen
und dieser Geschichte von diesem
leistungslosen Einkommen das mag
vielleicht gelten im Bereich der
Steuerklasse 3 bei Erbschaften also
beispielsweise bei einer Erbschaft von
Großcousin aus den USA oder dem
Vermächtnis von der guten Freundin und
in diesen Fällen da haben wir ja ganz
bewusst einen ganz niedrigen Freibetrag
und wir besteuern in diesen Fällen ja
auch des Erbe mit einem Steuersatz von
bis zu 50% und das ist völlig in Ordnung
in diesem Bereich wir sprechen aber hier
gerade bei unserem Antrag über den aller
engsten Familienkreises geht um
Ehepartner es geht um Kinder es geht um
die Enkel und in diesem engen Bereich in
diesem engen Bereich der Familie da hat
sich der Staat so weit als möglich
herauszuhalten und das gilt auch für den
Fiskus
und wenn die Ampel jetzt durch das mit
dem ftp-geführten Finanzministerium die
steuerliche Bewertung von Immobilien
erhöht dann muss zum Schutz dieses engen
Familienverbundes gleichzeitig die
Freibeträge entsprechend angehoben
werden
seit über einem Jahrzehnt wurden die
Freibeträge nicht mehr angepasst und
wenn jetzt vom Finanzminister zusätzlich
an der bewertungsschraube gedreht wird
dann ist es zwingend dass man diesem
Antrag von uns folgt und die
entsprechenden Freibeträge anhebt wir
fordern neben der Möglichkeit zur
Regionalisierung die Anhebung der
Freibeträge bei Ehegatten von 500.000
auf
825.000 für Kinder von 400.000 auf
600.000 von Enkel von 200 auf 300.000
und bei Eltern und Großeltern auf
165.000 bei allen anderen Personen
halten wir eine moderate Anpassung von
20 auf 33.000 Euro für richtig nochmal
uns geht es vor allem um die Familie uns
geht es darum dass das Elternhaus in
einer Familie weiterhin steuerfrei
vererbt werden kann das gebietet im
übrigen auch schon der Respekt vor der
Leistung der ausbaugeneration und diese
Aufbaugeneration ist wichtig und sie
reden immer von Respekt zeigen Sie ihnen
hier weil das eben so sieht der sollte
unserem Antrag heute auch zustimmen
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
zur Eröffnung dieser Debatte auf Antrag
der Unionsfraktion im Hintergrund steht
eine Vorgabe des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts und nach
Immobilien beide Erbschaftssteuer nach
dem aktuellen Verkehrswert angesetzt
werden müssen es hat natürlich eine
erhebliche immobiliepreis
immobilienpreisveränderung in den
letzten Jahren gegeben jetzt im
Düsseldorf für die SPD-Fraktion
ich bin ja eigentlich froh dass die
Union heute den Antrag eingebracht hat
weil es wäre wirklich schade gewesen
wenn ich morgen meine drei mütige Rede
zum Jahre Steuergesetz hätte
missbrauchen müssen um dazu zu sprechen
weil die letzte öffentliche
Berichterstattung dazu war so breit dass
es auf jeden Fall ein bisschen
Aufklärungsarbeit verdient und da bin
ich froh dass ich heute 7 Minuten von
ihnen bekomme um dazu dann noch mal
Stellung zu nehmen was was beschließen
wir wirklich ich will erstmal ein
bisschen Aufklärungsarbeit leisten weil
die aus meiner Sicht auch eben in der
Rede ein bisschen zu kurz gekommen ist
die Grundlage dessen was wir momentan
tun ist ein Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes von 2006 das
hat festgestellt dass Vermögenswerte in
der Beschreibung von Erbschaften gleich
behandelt werden müssen das ist momentan
nicht der Fall deswegen verändern wir
jetzt auch die
immobilienbewertungsverordnung das ist
übrigens kein Thema was dem
Bundesfinanzminister zu verdanken ist
oder wo man eben gerne Schuld zuschieben
kann eingeleitet hat dieses Verfahren
der Bundesinnenminister von der CSU 2019
das ist glaube ich noch mal ganz wichtig
zu betonen einfach auch um die sachliche
Richtigstellung hier vorzunehmen
dazu kommt sie vermitteln immer wieder
den Eindruck dass wir die
Erbschaftssteuer selbst erhöhen würden
das tun sie indem sie ein bisschen damit
kokientieren indem sie Dinge auch
miteinander vermischen ich will noch mal
ganz klar sagen wir erhöhen die
Erbschaftssteuer nicht wir ändern die
Bewertungskriterien passen sie an das an
was das Bundesverfassungsgericht
vorgeschrieben hat wir setzen geltendes
Recht um das ist seriöse und gebotene
Regierungspolitik und um ehrlich zu sein
ist auch ziemlich alternativlos das
zeigt auch dass ihr eigener CSU
mindestens vor zwei Jahren bereits
eingeleitet hat
es ist dennoch wichtig auch noch mal zu
betonen was es heute bereits für
Privilegien und Freibeträge gibt weil
die wurden eben auch ein bisschen
ausgespart das ist glaube ich noch mal
ganz gut die auch zu betonen die
Freibeträge sind für Partner 500.000 €,
also eine halbe Million 400 000 € für
Kinder 200.000 € für Enkel dazu kommt
gerade bei Wohnimmobilien wichtig dass
wir natürlich auch keine
Grunderwerbsteuer verlangen das ist
Element der Wettbewerbsvorteil gegenüber
all denjenigen die nicht erben können
die müssen nämlich Grunderwerbsteuer
zahlen das ist häufig vergessen ob man
ganz wichtiger Punkt und ein Punkt der
eben auch nicht erwähnt worden ist weil
immer mit Omas Häuschen argumentiert
wird
die Vermietung die Übertragung selbst
genutzter Immobilien bis 200
Quadratmeter Wohnfläche ist sowieso
steuerfrei das Immobilie die Immobilie
kann 2,5 Millionen Euro kosten ich kann
wenn ich da selber einziehen die
steuerfrei übernehmen wo ist da ihre
Gerechtigkeitslücke das ist bereits
gerecht und das wird ausreichend vom
Gesetz berücksichtigt
und jetzt kommen wir zum Thema
Vermietung weil das ja auch erwähnt wird
bereits da gilt auch ein verminderter
Wertansatz 90% und die Möglichkeit der
Stundungen über 10 Jahre also man kann
wirklich nicht davon sprechen dass hier
ein übergriffiges Finanzamt agiert das
hier irgendwie ungerecht Gelder wegnimmt
sondern es gibt eine ganze Reihe von
Privilegien die schon genutzt werden und
ich will über die
Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten gar nicht
sprechen alle zehn Jahre Schenkung
vornehmen versteckt Optionen
betrieblichen Vermögen Stiftung dass ich
da noch mal informieren will kann auch
gerne an die Finanzausschuss Mitglieder
der CDU CSU sich wenden weil die sind im
hauptberuflich noch als Steuerberater
oder Fachanwälte für erbschaftsrecht
tätig also da wird man sicherlich gute
Beratung bekommen
[Applaus]
sie schüren Ängste um Interessen
durchzusetzen und das tun sie ganz
bewusst niemand hier will Omas Häuschen
wegnehmen wir schützen das hart
arbeitete Wohneigentum wir schützen
klein und mittlere vermögen wir schützen
Omas Häuschen wir wollen aber auch
Gerechtigkeit und Chancengleichheit
dafür steht die Sozialdemokratie
und ich möchte da auch noch mal auf das
Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgericht von
2016 abheben und das darf ich kurz
zitieren die Erbschaftssteuer ist ein
Beitrag zur Herstellung sozialer
Chancengleichheit sie sich in der freien
Ordnung nicht von selbst herstellt die
Erbschaftssteuer wird der Gefahr
entgegen dass durch eine zunehmende
Ungleichverteilung von Mitteln die
Chancen auf gesellschaftliche wie
politische Teile habe auseinanderdriften
und sich so letztlich Einfluss und Macht
zunehmend unabhängig von individueller
Leistung verfestigen und dann Herkunft
gebunden sind das ist die Kern äh
Aufgabe der Erbschaftssteuer und
deswegen ist sie auch weiterhin gerecht
und muss auch von uns aufrecht halten
werden und sogar eigentlich noch
verschärft werden dazu komme ich aber
gleich und jetzt komme ich zum zum
Vergleich zur Diskussion zum Bürgergeld
hat nämlich Friedrich Merz sie haben
gesagt zum Bürgergeld der Grundsatz dass
man in Deutschland mit Arbeit mehr Geld
verdient als ohne muss ohne wenn und
aber auch heute und für die Zukunft
gelten unabhängig davon dass es beim
Bürgergeld stimmt und dass wir das auch
immer wieder betont haben dass es
richtig ist was sagen sie in deinem
Kontext zuerst dazu ich habe nicht dafür
gearbeitet wenn ich von meinen Eltern
Haus Erbe dafür haben meine Eltern
gearbeitet für mich ist das
leistungsloses Einkommen und deswegen
ist es auch gerecht dass der Staat das
besteuert
und es lohnt sich auch noch mal in der
Gesamtbetrachtung die Zahlen aufzuführen
wir haben 2021 in Deutschland rund 400
Milliarden Euro Erbschaften und
Schenkung zu verzeichnen davon werden
rund 11 Milliarden Euro Steuern
festgesetzt das ist ein
durchschnittlicher Steuersatz von 2,7 %
im Verhältnis zum Gesamtvolumen im
Vergleich das mittlere Arbeitseinkommen
ungefähr 50.000 € brutto im Jahr wird im
Durchschnitt mit 23% besteuert wir
können also wirklich nicht davon reden
dass Erbschaften deutlich stärker oder
gar ungerecht besteuert werden wer hat
arbeitet in dieser Gesellschaft der muss
Steuern zahlen aber nicht die reichen
Erben die müssen keine Steuern und die
obersten zehn Prozent
erhalten übrigens auch die Hälfte aller
Erbschaften es ist jetzt nicht so dass
es ein breites gesellschaftliches
Phänomen ist über die Hälfte bekommt gar
keine Erbschaften die obersten zehn
Prozent erhalten die Hälfte der
Erbschaften und Schenkung das ist glaube
ich auch noch mal ganz wichtig zu
betonen um das ins Verhältnis zu setzen
und Herren ich freue mich dass Sie der
Debatte beiwohnen ich habe mir die Mühe
gemacht noch mal zu suchen nach Daten
die sie bisher zu dem Thema geäußert
haben und da gibt es ja nicht so viel zu
finden aber einen doch ganz
interessantes Zitat was glaube ich den
meisten gar nicht bekannt ist sie haben
im Vorwege der Bundestagswahl als
Experte des Team Laschet für Wirtschaft
und Finanzen folgenden Satz gesagt oder
folgende beiden Sätze in der Folge einer
Reihe von verfassungsgerichtsurteilen
muss das sogenannte
familiengebrauchsvermögen im
erbschaftsstollenfrei bleiben ich habe
das eben erwähnt es bleibt auch
steuerfrei das selbstgenutzte
Wohneigentum ist steuerfrei das ist das
familiengebrauchsvermögen wenn das
darüber hinausgehende Vermögen mit
niedrigen Steuersätzen breiter besteuert
werden soll kann man darüber reden das
ist ja ganz interessant das ist unter
der Headline übrigens tituliert worden
März offen für erbschaftssteuererhöhung
und heute kommen Sie mit dem Antrag um
die Ecke ich muss sagen das ist so eine
interessante Wandlung die sie auch hier
vorgenommen haben
aus unserer Sicht ist hier also eine
ganzheitliche Reform notwendig ganz ganz
wichtig wir müssen endlich die
Privilegien der betrieblichen Vermögen
entziehen wir müssen endlich dafür
sorgen dass die die wirklich Kohle haben
in dieser Gesellschaft ordentlich
besteuert werden wir müssen die
schenkungsfristen verändern und dann
können wir auch darüber reden ob man
Freibeträge anhebt ansonsten ist das mit
uns nicht zu machen wir leben diesen
Antrag ab herzlichen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
soweit Tim flüssendorf für die
SPD-Fraktion der sitzt übrigens eben
Ausschuss für Finanzen wie viele der
Redner die wir jetzt hier in diesem
Tagesordnungspunkt 68 Minuten angesetzte
höheren werden jetzt als nächster Redner
Albrecht Glaser afd-fraktion Präsidentin
meine Damen und Herren die Erbschaft und
Schenkungssteuer war immer prekär sie
knüpft nicht an einer
erwerbswirtschaftliche Tätigkeit oder an
den Konsum an sondern greift in die
vermögensubstanz ein sie stellt eine
legalisierte Enteignung da
ja das Sterben typischerweise für
Menschen eine schmerzliche Angelegenheit
ist und das Schenken als ethisch positiv
und sozial wertvoll angesehen wird
erstaunt immer wieder dass diese
Ereignisse bzw Verhaltensweisen zum
Anlass genommen werden für eine extrem
invasive fiskalische Intervention
zum Beispiel im Jahre 1997 das oder
Hochwasser viele persönliche berufliche
Existenzen waren bedroht es gab große
Hilfsbereitschaft etwa gegenüber
handlagern die gerade auf die Füße
gekommen waren
Verwandte Freunde und Berufskollegen
haben sich ökonomisch engagiert
wenn durch solche Initiativen etwa für
die Neuausstattung einer Werkstatt
Gegenstände im Wert von 300.000 Euro
schenkweise zugewendet wurden wurde eine
solche Aktion mit 84.000 Euro
Schenkungssteuer belegt sofort zu
entrichten durch den
bei der Erbschaftssteuer kommt ihr
Besonderheit des Eingriffs in den
Familienverband hinzu und das Problem
der Zerschlagung von Unternehmen und
zwar speziell im Mittelstand weil die
Steuersätze von 20 30 oder 40% bezogen
auf die Verkehrswerte solcher
Unternehmen solche Steuerlasten nicht
getragen werden können dieses Problem
beschäftigt das Verfassungsgericht der
Kollege hat eine Entscheidung gelernt es
gibt aber mehrere dazu und die
Gesetzgebung seit vielen Jahren
unerlässig allein zwischen 2008 und
heute hat es beim Bewertungsgesetz und
beim Erbschaft schenkungsgesetz jeweils
über 100 Änderungen gegeben so wird hier
herumgewusstet
in der Zeit behandelten Jahr
Steuergesetz wird erneut das
bewerbungsgesetz unter anderem in der
Paragrafen 787 und 88 geändert es geht
dabei um Parameter der Bewertung
bebauter Grundstücke die beabsichtigte
Änderung bedeutet Werterhöhung gegenüber
dem bisherigen Bewertungsverfahren
dies geschieht vor dem Hintergrund seit
Jahren explodierender Immobilienpreise
und betrifft Millionen von Bürgern diese
von böserung des Rechtes ist daher
abzulegen
die Verteuerung von Eigentumswohnungen
betrug in den letzten zehn Jahren 130
Prozent der Hauspreisindex ist von 82 im
Jahr 2008 auf 154 im Jahr 21 gestiegen
also um 90 Prozent
erstaunlicherweise gibt es darauf keine
Reaktion der Bundesregierung und der
Ampelkoalition die Wertverhältnisse
haben sich seit über 10 Jahren als die
heutigen Freibeträge und Wertgrenzen
festgelegt worden so drastisch verändert
das vergleichbar zu Einkommensteuer das
Festhalten an nominalen Werten der
Vergangenheit eine Verfälschung des
seinerzeitigen gesetzgeberischen willens
ist meine Damen und Herren es müssen
also nicht nur die Freibeträge sondern
auch die Werte der progressiven
Steuertarife in den drei Steuerklassen
im Paragraph 19 Erbschaft
Schenkungssteuer angepasst werden und
dies aus verfassungsrechtlichen Gründen
meine Damen und Herren
erstaunlicherweise nimmt die 10 der
CDU-Antrag nur die Freibeträge in den
Blick was ich nicht verstehe stattdessen
ist eine sofortige Anpassung der
Wertgrenzen aus denen sich die
tarifbelastung ergibt und der Höhe der
Freibeträge vorzunehmen das eine tun und
das andere auch und wir brauchen zumal
bei den obwaltenden inflationsstypen
eine automatische Indexierung wie wir
sie auch in der Einkommensteuer
anschreiben und sogar seit ein paar
Jahren einigermaßen ordentlich
hinbekommen meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren mehr Rechtsstaat braucht das
Land herzlichen Dank
ist aber der Beitrag von Albrecht Glaser
für die afd-fraktion Mitglied im
Finanzausschuss wir werden es gleich
erleben die Rednerin der grünfraktion
Katharina Berg der wird ungefähr noch
mal die Argumentation
haben spannend wird dann der Redebeitrag
von der FDP-Fraktion in der Ampel ist
das nämlich nicht ganz homogen
verehrte Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen liebe Bürgerinnen und
Bürger Sie hier im Raum wissen alle dass
mir Konstruktivität am Herzen liegt aber
dieser Antrag ist leider nicht
konstruktiv anstatt sich Gedanken
darüber zu machen wie wir die Krise in
diesem Land angehen und den Unternehmen
und Menschen helfen können dies wirklich
dringend brauchen kommt die cdu/csu
jetzt mit einem Antrag zur Erhöhung der
Freibeträge bei Erbschaften das erkennt
die aktuelle Problematik in unserem Land
überhaupt nicht an und es auch
verfassungsrechtlich einen sagen wir mal
vorsichtig mutiger move zum aktuellen
Kontext es ist eine die Grundfesten
unserer Industrie und unsere sozialen
wertversprechens erschütternde Krise und
Inflation Unternehmen leiden unter den
hohen Energiepreisen die von Ihnen als
CDU maßgeblich mit verursachte
klumpenabhängigkeit von russischem Gas
in Höhe von 55% für zu dramatischen
Konsequenzen für unsere Wirtschaft wir
als moderne wirtschaftskoalition machen
dieses Land nun mit einer
Diversifikation Strategie in nie
dagewesenem Tempo und Dynamik
zukunftsfest
und zu den Menschen etwa 40 Prozent der
Menschen in unserem Land haben praktisch
kein eigenes Vermögen die Inflation
trifft die untere Mitte am härtesten
noch dazu jedes fünfte Kind lebt in
Kinderarmut auch das ist alles leider
ihr politisches Erbe mit dem wir jetzt
umgehen müssen und noch viel mehr
Menschen etwa 70 Prozent Erben überhaupt
gar nicht ihr Antrag bezieht sich ganz
klar auf die Menschen die in dieser
Krise stärkere Schultern haben und die
in einer ganz großen Mehrzahl auch sehr
solidarisch diese starken Schultern
gerne für unsere Gesellschaft tragen und
dafür bin ich sehr dankbar
die Haushaltsmittel die wir aktuell
einsetzen und einsetzen müssen die
müssen wir fokussieren auf die
Unternehmen und auf die Menschen die es
wirklich brauchen das sind nicht die 30
Prozent Erben denn sondern das sind
genau die vielen Millionen Menschen und
Unternehmen die nicht wissen wie sie in
ihre Energierechnung bezahlen können und
ich kann ganz klar sagen dass wir das in
der Regierung mit nie da gewesen und so
zielgenauen entlastungspaketen wie
möglich mit Preis bremsen und
strategischer Energiepolitik vor allem
im Bereich der freiheitsenergien beherzt
in die Tat umsetzen
stattdessen versuchen Sie hier heute
eine stellvertreterdebatte aufzumachen
um abzulenken dass sie eben keinen guten
Plan für Deutschland haben sie wollen
sich als Freunde von Omas Häuschen
aufspielen dabei sind Erbschaften und
Schenkungen in Deutschland sowie auch
das Vermögen an sich sehr ungleich und
bei wenigen verteilt die meisten Omas
haben überhaupt kein Häuschen wie gesagt
etwa 70% der Menschen Erben gar nicht
und zwei dritte der erb Schenkung gehen
nur an die 20 Prozent vermögensten
Menschen in Deutschland Erbinnen in
Deutschland gehören dort einer
DIW-Studie meist ohnehin zu den
privilegiertesten vor allem in
Westdeutschland mit ohnehin schon hohem
Vermögen und hohem Einkommen
in meiner Rede zur Ungleichverteilung in
Deutschland habe ich in der vorletzten
Sitzungswoche einen mir sehr wichtigen
Punkt gemacht Vermögen also schlicht
gesagt Geld ist vor allem ein Mittel zur
Erfüllung von Bedürfnissen und dem
Endeffekt für Freiheit und Teilhabe
Möglichkeit und zur Erinnerung diese
Freiheiten sind leider sehr ungleich
verteilt das Vermögens der erst ein
Prozent der Erwachsenen besitzt etwa 45%
des Gesamtvermögens und damit sogar
etwas mehr als 90% der gesamten
Erwachsenen in unserem Land und nur
Vermögen kann vererbt werden Erbschaften
und Schenkungen sind leider ein großer
Treiber für die Zementierung der hohen
Ungleichheit in Deutschland und mir ist
beim Thema Erben vor allem der
Leistungsgedanke wichtig inzwischen wird
das meiste private Vermögen durch
Erbschaften oder Schenkungen generiert
und nicht durch die eigene Arbeit
effektiv muss man aber auf das völlig
leistungslose Erben mit ca 2%
durchschnittlich ca 20 mal weniger
Steuern und Abgaben zahlen als auch die
eigene Hände Arbeit das ist einfach
krachend ungerecht für das
Leistungsversprechen und die Möglichkeit
sich selbst etwas aufzubauen ohne in die
entsprechenden Familien hineingeboren zu
sein in diesem Land natürlich kann man
auch ohne über Lohnnebenkosten reden
aber der ganz viel größere Bedarf
besteht doch darin wie wir mit der
Zementierung von sehr ungerechten
Vermögensverhältnissen in Deutschland
und mit der Erosion des
Leistungsversprechens und damit auch der
Demokratie und der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft umgehen die durch das
nahezu kostenfreie Erben leider auch mit
verursacht wird
wir müssen bei der Erbschaftssteuer wie
beim Thema Ungleichheit die Debatte aus
der tabu-ecke in eine positive
gestaltungsdiskussion für unser Land
bringen und zum verfassungsrechtlichen
die Wertanpassung die wir im
Jahressteuergesetz vornehmen sind
verfassungsmäßig vorgegeben aber auf
eine Art haben sie ja völlig Recht als
Union sehr wahrscheinlich besteht auch
verfassungsrechtlich noch weitere
Reformbedarf um die Erbschaftssteuer im
Einklang mit unserem Grundgesetz zu
halten aber wenn man das ändern würde
dann müsste man die Erbschaftssteuer
eben grundsätzlich angehen zuletzt 2014
erklärte das Bundesverfassungsgericht
nach 2006 aufs Neue dass das
Erbschaftssteuerrecht verfassungswidrig
sei der Grund eben das Ausmaß und die
ausgestalt der Steuerbefreiungen waren
mit dem Grundrecht der steuerlichen
belastungsungleichheit nicht vereinbar
und wir alle hier wissen dass das was
2016 dann als Reform beschlossen wurde
er ein Reformversuch war der die
eigentlich bemängelten Probleme eben
nicht tatsächlich vorgehoben hat
Beispiel
verschonungsbedarfsprüfung die bedeutet
im Endeffekt das besonders reiche
Erbinnen im Zweifel mit nicht allzu
komplizierten Mitteln im Endeffekt dann
überhaupt nichts bezahlen müssen die vom
Verfassungsgericht bemängelten Probleme
sind augenscheinlich nicht wirklich
gelöst und auch im Immobilienbereich
gibt es eine fast schon skurrile
Ausnahme für die Verschonung von
Wohnimmobilien die normalerweise nicht
als steuerbefreites Betriebsvermögen
zählen können wenn 300 oder mehr
Wohneinheiten hingegen vererbt werden
handelt es sich um ein
Wohnungsunternehmen was dann auch von
der Steuer befreit ist diese Regel hat
der Bundesfinanzhof bereits bemängelt
ihr Antrag Liebe Union ist leider ein
billiger Versuch zu spalten und Ängste
zu führen dieses Land hält aber zusammen
darauf bin ich stolz wenn es ihnen
ernsthaft und mehr Leistungs- und
Chancengerechtigkeit geht bin ich aber
sofort bereit mit Ihnen grundlegend über
eine Reform der Erbschaftsteuer zu
sprechen vielen Dank
Katharina Beck ist die finanzpolitische
Sprecherin der Bündnis grünen Fraktion
die Erbschaftssteuer hat nach ihrer
Position auch die Aufgabe
Gerechtigkeit abzubilden in dieser
Gesellschaft Christian Görke Sprecher
für Finanzpolitik der Linken Fraktion
da haben sie als Union ja einen Antrag
hervorgebracht der er richtig Sturm im
Wasserglas hier hervorruft denn der
andere lautet ja keine
erbschaftssteuererhöhung durch die
Hintertür aber die Realität ist bisher
hatten wir nur
erbschaftssteuersenkungen durch die
Hintertür und diese Tür meine Damen und
Herren wird jetzt geschlossen weil mit
dem Gesetz Immobilien und Grundstücke
endlich dem aktuellen Marktwert bei der
Erbschaftsteuer berücksichtigt werden
heißt während Zukunft erbt muss dann
auch den aktuellen Marktwerk für seine
geerbte Immobilien versteuern abzüglich
natürlich dieser auch durchaus
beachtenswerten Freibeträge nur fair
meine Damen und Herren das ist nur fair
schließlich werden Aktien Kunstgemälde
Ersparnisse auch zum Marktwerk hier
versteuert und es glaube ich auch nur
gerecht denn betroffen ist kaum Oma
klein Häuschen das zur Eigennutzung hier
benutzt wird sondern es geht doch
wirklich das wissen wir doch alle
luxusbuden und um die Erbschaften von
gleich mehreren Immobilien die jetzt
adressiert werden und liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von der Union manchmal
denke ich sie nutzen gerade
oberkleinhäuschen als Abwehr Schild
damit sie die Interessen von Multi
Multimillionären Erben so ein bisschen
argumentativ hier verstecken können und
wenn Sie meine Damen und Herren von der
Union wenn Sie diese
erbschaftssteuergerechter machen wollen
dann schaffen sie doch die Schlupflöcher
und Privilegien ab wie zum Beispiel
ein geerbter Bestand von 300 Wohnungen
der mit Tricks zum Betriebsvermögen
klassifiziert wird damit fast quasi
Steuer vorübergeht und da ging die Armen
von zwei Wohnungen ordentlich zahlt dann
hat das nichts mit Maß und Mitte zu tun
dann ist das eher für die die dann
zahlen eher eine dummensteuer denn und
da kommt noch hinzu je größer das Erbe
dass du niedriger der Steuersatz
2019 meine Damen und Herren
2019 haben in Deutschland allein 40
Multi Millionären insgesamt ein Vermögen
von 9,4 Milliarden Euro geerbt an
Steuern zahlten sie
172 Millionen das macht ein Schnitt mit
einem mini-steuersatz von 2% aus während
bei den kleinen und niedrigen
Erbschaften in Deutschland im Schnitt 9%
zu zahlen waren und diese
Ungerechtigkeit steht im Mittelpunkt und
an diese Ungerechtigkeit müssen wir ran
und da wo ist denn da meine Damen und
Herren von der Union ihr Vorschlag sie
reden Tag ein Tag aus hier vom
Leistungsprinzip und gönnen den Menschen
beim Bürgergeld nicht mal das schwarze
unter den Fingernägel Gängen die mit
Sanktionen aber wenn die Millionen und
Milliarden hier Steuerberater zu
steuerfrei durchlaufen ja dann habe ich
den Eindruck er Pudding denn sind sie
auf beiden Augen nicht sehen
und das hat mit harter Maloche kaum
etwas zu tun und wenn sie noch ein
Beispiel brauchen dann nehmen wir doch
mal Susanne Klatten die gerade aus der
Schule kam und mit einmal zur BMW
Großaktionären wurde wissen Sie meine
Damen und Herren von der Union das hat
das ist ein leistungsloses
Grundeinkommen meine Damen und Herren
Herz das ist ein leistungsloses
Grundeinkommen was hier hervorgerufen
wird und zum Schluss Herr putting ich
schätze sie sehr aber es war natürlich
heute ein bisschen schwierig für sie
denn die CDU und damals der
Innenminister Horst Seehofer hat ja
diese neuen Bewertungsregeln für
Immobilien unter Umgehung und der
Umgebung des Deutschen Bundestages als
Verordnung auf dem Weg gebracht und
insofern habe ich den Eindruck sie
agieren momentan nach dem Motto
was schert mich mein Geschwätz von
gestern
Görke sehr vom Fach jetzt Sprecher für
Finanzpolitik zwischen 2014 und 2019 war
er landesfinanzminister im Bundesland im
Brandenburg jetzt ganz spannend zu hören
Claudia Raffel Höschen von der
FDP-Fraktion der FDP hat ein bisschen
dezidiert andere Position als die
anderen ampelpartner
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen oft waren im
vergangenen Wochen zu hören dass die
Erbschaftsteuer erhöht würde das ist
natürlich totaler Quatsch eine
Erbschaftsbesteuerung von Immobilien ist
nicht geplant
Gesetzes über das jahressteuerge
setz sich umgesetzten Anpassung der
Immobilienwert ermittlungsverordnung die
damals insbesondere von der Union
vorangetrieben wurde sie war notwendig
da das Bundesverfassungsgericht zweimal
erst 2006 und dann erneut 2018 anmahnte
dass alles was vererbt wird
gleichermaßen zu bewerten ist egal ob es
ein Sparbuch ist ein Aktiendepot oder
eben auch eine Immobilie
nun sind in den vergangenen Jahren die
Immobilienpreise kontinuierlich und
deutlich angestiegen der
Immobilienbesitzer und spätere Erblasser
hat also auch tatsächlich ein höheres
Vermögen so dass auch ein höherer
Nachlass vererbt wird die angestrebte
Gerechtigkeit in der Immobilienbewertung
und späteren Erbschaftsbesteuerung ist
aber schon lange nicht mehr gegeben nach
dem bisherigen bewertungsprinzipien kann
es vorkommen dass der Verkehrswert
deutlich unterschritten wird hier
entsteht also eine Grauzone die laut
Verfassungsgericht nun geschlossen
werden muss durch die angestrebte
Neuregelung stellen wir nun sicher dass
die
grundbesitzbewertung zu einer
realistischeren Wert Ermittlung führt
diese Anpassung dienen dazu die realen
Wertverhältnisse am Immobilienmarkt
abzubilden
unangetastet bleibt zum Beispiel die
Möglichkeit für den Erben einen
niedrigeren Verkehrswert durch ein
Gutachten zu erbringen auch bleibt es
bei dem bisherigen Regelungen dass ein
Familienheim im Falle des Todes
steuerfrei auf den Ehepartner oder die
Kinder vererbt werden kann denn klar ist
wer sich etwas aufbaut für seine Familie
vorsorgt dessen Erben dürfen dafür nicht
bestraft werden
aus diesem Grund liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union ist es wieder
gerecht noch fair solche Grauzonen nun
einfach zu dulden denn es ist weder
verfassungskonform noch bürokratisch
sinnvoll außerdem war es auch ihnen in
16 Jahren Regierungszeit durchaus
bekannt dass die Immobilienpreise massiv
ist ansteigen dass die aktuellen
bewertungsregelung verfassungsrechtlich
fragwürdig sind und eine neue Regelung
unausweichlich ist das hätte auf dem
damaligen baumminister sehr hoch aus
ihren Reihen bekannt sein müssen
die nun plötzlich in ihrem Antrag
formulierte Forderung nach einer
Erhöhung der Freibeträge wirkt also
wenig glaubwürdig sie hätten es bis vor
gut einem Jahr selbst umsetzen können
haben die Freibeträge aber seit 2009
nicht angetastet
das sind 13 Jahre wir regieren nun seit
einem Jahr und schließen nun erstmal die
von ihnen hinterlassenen
Steuerschlupflöcher
aber und das will ich in aller
Deutlichkeit sagen es war unser
Fraktionsvorsitzender Christian Dörr der
kürzlich genau diese Debatte um die
Erhöhung der Freibeträge öffentlich
angestoßen hat auch koalitionsintern
diskutieren wir das und werden unsere
Liberalen Überzeugung selbstbewusst in
der Debatte einfließen lassen das
verspreche ich Ihnen
so wie bei der kalten Progression im
Einkommen Steuerrecht sollte auch die
Erbschaftssteuer an die Inflation
angepasst werden um reale
Steuererhöhungen die nicht
parlamentarisch legitimiert sind zu
vermeiden
wenn man nun eine Erhöhung der
Freibeträge anstrebt was wir durchaus
unterstützen müssen wir uns fragen ob
wir ob das nicht zu kurz greift müssten
wir nicht auch über ein vollständig
indexierten Steuertarif in allen
erbschaftssteuerstufen sprechen denn nur
so kann der inflationären Erhöhung der
realen Besteuerung entgegengewirkt
werden
wichtig ganz wichtig ist uns dass eine
solch komplexe Entscheidung nicht übers
Knie gebrochen wird in der Koalition
stehen wir für konstruktive und vor
allem legitime Lösung und nicht für
Schnellschüsse und daher lehnen wir
Ihren Antrag ab und ganz nebenbei
bemerkt eine Erhöhung der Freibeträge
führt auf der anderen Seite natürlich in
den Ländern zu Steuer Mindereinnahmen da
wir hier
wie auch in anderen Bereichen keinerlei
Kompromissbereitschaft im Bundesrat
sehen wäre ein Gesetzesentwurf nicht
mehr als heiße Luft und eine reine
schaufensterde Debatte zeigen sie doch
liebe cdu/csu einen wirklichen
lösungswillen auch im Bundesrat indem
sie die Mehrheit haben wir hoffen in
Zukunft auf eine ehrliche ihre
Oppositionsarbeit vielen Dank
da war noch eine kleine Shelter Richtung
Union drin aber durchaus in der Sache
auch noch mal der Hinweis dass ich die
FDP dem Gedanken öffnen kann einen
indexierte Anpassung von
Erbschaftssteuer vorzunehmen mal schauen
wie wir die nächste Position hören von
der Union Sebastian
erster Fakt die Ampel hat einen
Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt der
unzweifelhaft in sehr vielen Fällen zu
einer deutlich höheren Erbschaft und
Schenkungsteuer führen wird
zweiter Fakt die Ampel erhöht der Ball
nicht die Erbschaft und Schenkungssteuer
direkt sondern sie ändert die
steuerlichen
Bewertungsmaßstäbe dadurch werden Häuser
und Wohnungen steuerlich wesentlich
wertvoller eingeschätzt bei einem
unveränderten Steuersatz kommt es hierzu
zu einer deutlichen Erhöhung der
Erbschaft und Schenkungssteuer liebe
Kolleginnen und den Ballungsräumen in
Ballungsräumen kann es sogar bei der
Berechnung zu einer Verfünffachung der
Erbschaft und Schenkungssteuer kommen
wenn man die Freibeträge nicht anpasst
und die neuen
Bewertungsmaßstäbe liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen weil es angesprochen worden ist
mögen verfassungsrechtlich geboten sein
aber es steht nirgends es steht nirgends
dass es verfassungsrechtlich in diesem
Jahr umgesetzt werden muss und es ist
auch wenn Sie diesen dieses Argument
einfügen dass die Häuser und Wohnungen
im Preis gewonnen haben und der zugelegt
haben dann müssen sie zwingend auch das
Argument gelten lassen die Freibeträge
in gleichen Maße zu erhöhen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und das tun sie
nicht auch ziemlich von der FDP auch
wenn sie es hier in der Rede als
oppositionsrede sozusagen vortragen
Dritter Fakt der Gesetzentwurf im Jahre
Steuergesetz 2022 ist nicht aus dem
damaligen Innenministerium gekommen das
ist die glatte Unwahrheit und verdreht
alle Tatsachen die haben sie auch heute
wieder behauptet nein der Gesetzentwurf
kommt aus dem FDP geführten
Finanzministerium und der kommt von
Christian Lindner Christian Lindner und
die FDP greifen in die Taschen der Erben
das ist die Wahrheit liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und das muss hier auch mal
gesagt werden
der Gesetzentwurf kommt von einer Partei
die im Wahlkampf noch gesagt hat
übrigens zurecht
steuererhöhungen sind Sabotage am
Aufschwung und sie kommt von einer
Partei deren Chef vor vier Tagen lieber
Herr Lindner vor vier Tagen am 28
November beim Zentralverband des
Deutschen Handwerks gesagt haben und ich
zitiere wir sind in der
Vorweihnachtszeit fürchtet euch nicht
mit dieser Koalition und mit diesen
Finanzminister wird es keine
Steuererhöhungen geben sie zwingt keiner
von dieser Haltung Abstand zu nehmen
lieber Kollege Lindner wenn Sie eine
Erhöhung der Immobilienbewertung
durchsetzen müssen dann erhöhen Sie
bitte auch die Freibeträge in
gleichermaßen deswegen helfen wir heute
mit unserem Antrag
sie machen die Menschen in unserem Land
bewusst wieder
ärmer und sie nehmen den Menschen in
unserem Land ihr hart erspartes Geld
einfach weg Kollege Bremen und man kann
ja bitte bestatten sie eine Frage oder
Bemerkung des Kollegen Schmidt
selbstverständlich gerne
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Priem vielen
Dank Frau Präsidentin für das gestatten
der Zwischenfrage Herr prägen sie sagen
wir würden die Menschen in Deutschland
ärmer machen
jetzt kann ja jetzt das Argument
verstehen dass durch die steigende
Inflationsrate tatsächlich die
Wertsteigerungen in der Form bisschen
Körper ankommen als von uns erwartet
oder erwünscht nichts desto weniger
müsste man sich doch jetzt auch mal die
Wertentwicklung anschauen die Immobilien
genommen haben im Vergleich zur
Inflationsrate ist ihnen klar dass sie
Inflationsrate in den letzten Jahren
immer so um hier mal Daumen zwischen
einem halben und zwei Prozent war jetzt
in den aktuellen Jahr bei 8% allein die
Immobilienpreise sich aber nur in 10
Jahren alleine um 65% gesteigert haben
ist es da nicht nur fair und richtig
diese enormen Wertsteigerungen der
Immobilien auch entsprechend moderat zu
besteuern wie es ja mit der
Erbschaftssteuer Zylinder Fall ist
Liebe Kollege Schmidt fair und richtig
wäre wenn man diese 65% Wertsteigerung
die sie erwähnen auch im Freibetrag
abbilden würde weil ich sage Ihnen eins
wenn man mal nehmen wir mal nehmen wir
mal unseren Großraum bei uns in Nürnberg
ein normales kleines Reihenhaus ist
inzwischen bei einem Wert von 750 bis
800.000 Euro und das soll vielleicht
vererbt werden von einer Generation die
hart gearbeitet hat die keinen Urlaub
gemacht hat die sich das abgespart hat
weil es der nächsten Generation besser
gehen soll und die vererben des jetzt an
die nächste Generation und sagen die
Familie soll da rein aber vielleicht
muss sie beruflich auch wieder umziehen
und dann greifen Sie in die Tasche und
nehmen es weg deshalb ersparte von den
Menschen übrigens sind auch
wahrscheinlich ihre Wähler wo man das
Geld wegnimmt insofern sehe ich es nicht
so wie sie ich glaube wenn Sie eine
Erhöhung der Immobilienwerte abbilden
wollen im Gesetz dann müssen Sie auch
zwingen sind eine Erhöhung der
Freibeträge vornehmen ansonsten machen
sie die Menschen einfach ärmer
liebe Kollegen
die Frage ist warum das nicht im Gesetz
umgesetzt ist obwohl es der
Finanzminister obwohl es der
Finanzminister auch angekündigt hat die
Freibeträge zu erhöhen und warum die FDP
hat er auch gerade gesagt sie ist dafür
warum ist es nicht umgesetzt
ja gerne lassen sie auch eine Frage oder
Bemerkung aus der SPD-Fraktion
Herr Bremen ja vielen Dank dass Sie die
Frage zulassen weil es geht darum dass
sie Behauptungen jetzt aufgestellt haben
eine Rechnung aufgemacht haben die doch
noch mal zu hinterfragen sind übrigens
ich komme aus Bayern ich komme aus der
Nähe von München und ich weiß dass du
die Wertstellung sehr hoch sind nehmen
wir gesetzt an es gibt ein Reihenhaus
wie sie gesagt haben ein reineckhaus das
ist in den letzten zehn Jahren hat sich
da Wert verdoppelt das war vielleicht
bei 500.000 €, wenn er gekauft wurde
jetzt eine Million 1,2 Millionen Euro
wert jetzt haben wir gesetzt die
Situation die Eltern sterben es kommt
zum Erbfall es gibt zwei Kinder es gibt
erstens mal Herr Bremer sie unerwähnt
lassen schon die Möglichkeit über
Schenkungen alle zehn Jahre pro Kind und
Elternteil
400.000 Euro steuerfrei weiterzugeben
das wäre bei einem solchen innerhalb von
einem von einem Jahr das komplette
komplette Wert eines Haus weiter
verschenkt ohne das steueranfällt und
genauso fällt das ganze auch an beim
Erbschaftsfall bei zwei Kindern und zwei
Eltern das heißt also Herr Bremen wenn
ich Ihre Rechnung richtig verstehe und
sie ihr Haus in Nürnberg benennen dass
das mit den heutigen Freibeträgen bei
zwei Kindern schon vollständig
steuerfrei übergeht mal bei der Tatsache
wenn es selbst bewohnt wird das bis zu
200 Quadratmeter diese Wohnfläche
vollkommen steuerfrei übergeht wenn es
selbst bewohnt wird wo bitteschön ist
ihr Skandal denn sie hier hochziehen
wollen den es gar nicht gibt
ihre Rechnung geht ja nicht auf
wenn Sie das ist eine
sozialdemokratische
Rechnung der Umverteilung wenn Sie Ihr
Haus in München annehmen und zwei Kinder
erben dann werden sie das Haus verkaufen
müssen um die Erbschaftssteuer zu
bezahlen und was passiert doch das ist
der Fakt das ist der Fakt ich kann Ihnen
aus der Realität berichten in der sie
leider nicht immer zu Hause sind dass
das der Fakt ist lieber Kollege und ich
sage Ihnen sie fordern jetzt die
Menschen auf sie fordern jetzt die
Menschen auf ihr Erspartes schon jetzt
an die Kinder zu übertragen aber
überlegen Sie mal manche wollen ihr
spart ist auch ein Stück zurückbehalten
weil wenn sie in Pflege kommen oder ein
ein bei der Rente Geld brauchen dann
können Sie jetzt noch nicht vererben
weil dann das Häuschen eben schon auf
der nächsten Generation lass dir
deswegen ist Ihre Rechnung falsch und
beachten Sie mal auch eines diese zehn
Jahre bei 200 Quadratmetern da muss man
ja zehn Jahre Personen in der heutigen
Arbeitswelt kann das passieren dass man
vielleicht von München nach Hamburg geht
Frau Kollegin Beck und dann ist die
Erbschaftssteuer zu zahlen und dann muss
man eben den Umzug bezahlen und die
Erbschaftssteuer und muss das Haus
verkaufen das ist die Realität in
Deutschland und die können sie nicht
leugnen sie können sie nicht leugnen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Frage
ist ja die Frage ist ja wenn der
Finanzminister des gefordert hat die
Freibeträge anzupassen ist es dann
Absicht dass es jetzt nicht im Gesetz
ist oder ist es rot-grüne Umverteilung
wir haben ja in der letzten
Sitzungswoche auch über Vermögensabgabe
überlastenausgleich gesprochen den sie
befürwortet haben als es sie wollen erst
50 Prozent des Vermögens wegnehmen und
dann auch noch mit Erbschaftssteuer
besteuern das ist die eigentliche Plan
sie wollen dass die Menschen in unserem
Land kein Vermögen mehr haben sie
sprechen im Wahlkampf von Respekt sie
sprechen im Wahlkampf von Respekt
die Menschen die hart arbeiten die früh
aufstehen die sich was ersparen die
nicht in den Urlaub fahren diejenigen
die was für die nächste Generation
schaffen wollen den nehmen Sie das
Vermögen Weg das ist respektlos liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vor den
Menschen die hart arbeiten das ist
respektlos
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
höhere Steuer wird doch dazu führen
dass Erben ihr Elternhaus verkaufen
müssen um die höhere Erbschaftssteuer zu
bezahlen
sie wird davor zu führen dass
einheimische an Investoren verkaufen
oder an gewerbliche Interessenten und
sie wird dazu führen dass es zu
drastischen Mieterhöhungen kommt damit
sind sie die mieterhöhungspartei in
Deutschland Nummer eins droht grün und
gelb liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
ist unsozial was da passiert
die Freibeträge liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sind seit 13 Jahren nicht
angepasst
und deswegen wenn wir die
Bewertungsmaßstäbe ansetzen dann
brauchen wir auch die Freibeträge und
wir bringen noch einen weiteren Aspekt
an der seit Jahren diskutiert wird und
richtig ist
wir wollen eine Regionalisierung der
Erbschaftssteuer prüfen weil es nämlich
auch die unterschiedlichen
Lebenswirklichkeiten in den
unterschiedlichen Bundesländern abbildet
und der Kollege Lindner sie haben gesagt
die Initiative soll von den Ländern
kommen jetzt kommt die Initiative von
den Ländern im Bundesrat dann erwarte
ich aber auch ihre Zustimmung zu diesem
Gesetz und ihre Zustimmung auch übrigens
heute es wird sich zeigen ob sie es
ernst meine liebe Frau Kollege
raffelhöschen wenn Sie hier sagen es
muss eine Erhöhung der Werte geben dann
stimmen sie jetzt unserem Antrag zu oder
sie zeigen den Menschen da draußen dass
es ihnen egal ist was sie gestern
vorgestern oder vor vier Tagen gesagt
haben liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
Jahressteuergesetz morgen ist eine
Enteignung der fleißigen und eine
bewusste Verarmung der Vermögenden und
deswegen lehnen wir es abstimmen sie
heute unserem Antrag zu herzlichen Dank
der Unionsabgeordnete Sebastian brehmik
geht der CSU mit einem munteren
Austausch hier mit den Herren schrodi
SPD und Schmidt Bündnis 90 grüne die
sich hier durchaus auch
Bremen ist im echten Leben auch
Steuerberater über die Realität im
deutschen Erbschaftssteuerrecht noch
ausgetauscht haben nächster Redner
Lennart von der SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist schon
grotesk also immer wenn es hier um
Änderungen bei der Erbschaftssteuer geht
wenden sie als Gegner dieser Steuer
verlässlich dieselben
Kommunikationsstrategien an der
Bevölkerung wird suggeriert dass bei
Erbschaften künftig viel höhere Steuern
anfallen das wird unter füttert mit den
aller schlimmsten dramatischsten Horror
Szenarien Enkel müssen das von Oma
geerbte Haus verkaufen weil die
Steuerlast so stark steigt
Familienbetriebe werden an Hedgefonds
verkauft damit die Erben die
Steuerzahlungen leisten können es sollen
sich möglichst viele Menschen
angesprochen fühlen auch diejenigen die
vielleicht ein relativ normales Erbe
erwarten oder eventuell auch gar nichts
erben frei nach dem Motto Vorsicht der
Stadt will hier euch was wegnehmen
diese Strategie konnten wir zum Beispiel
2016 in voller Blüte beobachten als wir
die Erbschaftssteuer nach einer Reform
des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes das
letzte Mal reformiert haben und ihre
Familien wollten es gab damals nämlich
eine sehr aggressive lobby-kampagne die
bei ihnen in der Fraktion auf offene
Ohren Stoß und dann durch der gute
Reformvorschlag der das Betriebsvermögen
des Steuerprivileg bei den
Betriebsvermögen reformieren wollte am
Ende total verbessert wurde
wir haben gerade das ist ja am Ende die
große Ungerechtigkeit gerade bei den
hohen Erbschaften handelt es sich um
hohe Unternehmensanteile und wer
beispielsweise mehr als 20 Millionen
Euro erbt zahlt im Durchschnitt weniger
als zwei Prozent Erbschaftssteuer wir
hingegen weniger als 500.000 € erbt das
klassische Eigenheim etwa muss im
Durchschnitt über 10% Erbschaftssteuer
zahlen das ist nicht Maß das ist nicht
Mitte das ist die eigentliche
Ungerechtigkeit im
erbschaftssteuersystem
und aufgrund ihrer bekannten
Kommunikationsstrategie ist die
Erbschaftssteuer auch so unbeliebt
Befragung zeigen dass sich etwa 70%
gegen die Erbschaftssteuer aussprechen
dabei erbt die Mehrheit der Deutschen
überhaupt nicht tatsächlich Erben
weniger als 40 Prozent der Bevölkerung
in Deutschland etwas diejenigen die hart
morgens arbeiten die frühmorgens
Aufstehen die erarbeiten sich ihr
Vermögen durch Lohnarbeit und nicht
durch das Erben von höheren
Vermögenswerten und Immobilien
insgesamt ist auch die Höhe der
Erbschaften sehr ungleich verteilt zwei
Drittel aller Erbschaften gehen an die
obersten 20% der Vermögensverteilung
dabei geht es um richtig viel Geld ca
300 Milliarden Euro werden pro Jahr
vererbt dagegen ist das aufkommende
Erbschaftssteuer mit knapp 10 Milliarden
Euro eher gering und zeigt wie klein das
Problem eigentlich ist dass sie hier in
diesem Antrag so hochschreiben
es ist ja auch nicht so dass alle
Erbschaften voll versteuert werden die
Freibeträge sind angesprochen worden 500
000 € ca für Ehepartnerinnen und
Ehepartner bis zu 400 000 € für Kinder
200.000 € für Enkel auch der
selbstgenutzte Wohnraum muss von den
benannten Personengruppen überhaupt
nicht versteuert werden jedenfalls nicht
wenn der Erblasser zuvor in der
Immobilie gewohnt hat und die Erben dort
mindestens 10 Jahre weiterhin wohnen
also wer das berühmte normale Haus von
Oma und Opa erbt um darin zu wohnen der
wird in Deutschland keine
Erbschaftssteuer zahlen sie machen hier
aus der Mücke einen Elefanten und das
muss man ja mal deutlich machen
was ist der Anlass dieser Debatte des
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat den Auftrag
gegeben wir müssen dafür sorgen dass bei
der Berechnung der Erbschaftssteuer der
tatsächliche Wert für Immobilien also
der Verkehrswert verwendet wird und das
ist fair und richtig und das ist bei
anderen Vermögenswerten gar nicht der
Fall ist es schon der Fall bei
Immobilienwerten ist das oder nicht und
in diesem Zusammenhang das haben sie
schon gesagt ist die Immobilienwert
Ermittlung Verordnung geändert worden
und zwar von wem vom
Bundesinnenministerium und damaliger
Innenminister war richtig Horst Seehofer
von der CSU
die geänderte Verordnung soll nun auf
den Bewertungen auf das Bewertungsgesetz
der Erbschaftssteuer übertragen werden
das ist richtig das kommt von der vom
Bundesfinanzministerium es war aber von
allen zu erwarten es war nichts
Überraschendes es war keine Hintertür
keine Tricks wie Sie es hier versuchen
zu suggerieren
nee und das liegt daran also die neue
Berechnungsgrundlage führt natürlich
dazu dass der eine Immobilie höher
bewertet werden kann das liegt daran
dass der Wert einer Immobilie steigt das
haben sie eben gut beschrieben es kann
aber auch genau gegenteilig der Fall
sein Werte für Immobilien ändern sich
unterschiedlich und wie bereits erwähnt
in den allermeisten Fällen wird aufgrund
der Freibeträge und ist selbst genutzten
Wohneigentums gar keine Erbschaftssteuer
fällig werden
und obwohl die Union diese Änderung 2021
sie haben selbst eingeleitet ist die
sind sie sich heute nicht so schade wie
der diese klassische angstkampagne zu
führen flankiert wird diese Kampagne
dann meistens von den einschlägigen
Lobbyverbänden Anwaltskanzleien Notarin
die damit natürlich fleißig mitverdienen
und dazu kann man immer die die wirklich
die wildesten Rechenbeispiele die
kursieren dann zuerst in den sozialen
Medien und dann wird das dann von der
Tagespresse nachgeplappert und sie
senden eigentlich die Botschaft aus die
Ampel wird abkassieren wenn du
Wohneigentum erbst und das soll heimlich
still und leise eingeführt werden am
besten noch während die Uhr angehalten
gestanden sie eine Frage oder Bemerkung
des Kollegen stefinger
vielen Dank Herr Kollege vielen Dank
Frau Präsidentin dass sie die Frage
zulassen sie haben gerade Lobbyverbände
angesprochen Herr Kollege ich möchte
sich fragen wie sie denn die Aussagen
des Mietervereins München beurteilen der
hier sagt die Erbschaftssteuer führt
gerade in Ballungsräumen wie
beispielsweise München zu steigenden
Mieten
ich bin sicher dass bei diesem Thema es
nicht um ein Thema links oder rechts
geht sondern am Ende auch um ein Thema
wenn sich
Mietervereine und eigentümerverbände
hier einig sind dass die
Erbschaftssteuer auch ein mietreiber in
Ballungsräumen ist und dazu führen wird
Eigentum und ich darf mal darauf
hinweisen ich komme aus München in einer
Stadt in der 80 Prozent der
Mietwohnungen in Privateigentum sind
dass hier eine drastische Veränderung
eintreten wird bei den Mieten weil sich
nämlich viele Erben viele Erben die
Erbschaftssteuer gar nicht mehr leisten
können diese nicht bezahlen können es
sei denn sie erhöhen die Mieten
drastisch weil sie nur dann ein
Bankdarlehen bekommen oder sie verkaufen
an Investoren die dann nicht mehr neun
oder zehn Euro für den Quadratmeter
verlangen sondern 15 oder 20 Euro oder
sogar noch mehr wenn ich mir Innenstadt
lagen anschaue also von daher gerade und
doch das stimmt schon und da lade ich
Sie auch herzlich gerne nach München ein
aber ich glaube das gerade die SPD die
plakatiert hat auch Respekt
Mietern im Wahlkampf hier eine
entsprechende Rolle auch zu spielen hat
und ich rate Ihnen lazi herzlich ein
vielleicht unterhalten sie sich auch mit
Münchner Oberbürgermeister SPD zu diesem
Thema denn genau diese Erbschaftssteuer
und diese Bewertungsregeln führen auch
dazu dass Mietwohnungen verkauft werden
würden Sie das bitte anerkennen weil ich
stelle jetzt fest in dieser Debatte dass
weder die Linken noch die SPD noch die
Grünen irgendetwas hier auch für
günstige Mieten machen und von daher
möchte ich sie hier um Ihre Bewertung
bitten
Herr Kollege ich gehe ja gerne darauf
ein dass sie beschreiben das ist ja das
Problem was man in Bayern hat nämlich
das überhaupt der öffentlich der
Wohnraum den man den Smart der mein
öffentliche Hand war überhaupt fragt
privatisiert wurde das ist ja das
eigentliche Problem in der Wohnraum in
der Mietpreis Debatte ne und das ist
nicht nur ein bayerisches Problem das
ist auch ein hessisches Problem da würde
das Tafel Silber verscherbelt und ich
komme aus der Rhein-Main-Region ich weiß
sehr gut bevor sie reden nee aber ich
hatte eben angesprochen es gibt
Freibeträge gerade für die
unmittelbaren Erben für die Kinder auch
ich ähm meine Eltern haben einen Haus in
im Rhein-Main-Gebiet und meine Brüder
und ich werden es wahrscheinlich
irgendwann mal Erben aber mit diesem
Freibeträgen glaube ich wird es doch
weiterhin damit eine gute Lösung geben
und wie gesagt das Problem dass sie
eigentlich ansprechen ist das Problem
dass zu viel Wohnraum in privater Hand
ist und damals aus öffentliche Hand
natürlich verkauft wurde
ich fahre fort die Union nutzt natürlich
jetzt diese selbst initiierte Debatte
frühere Freibeträge zu fordern ich bin
der Meinung die aktuellen Freibeträge
und Regelungen reichen aus damit in den
meisten Fällen für selbstgenutztes
Wohneigentum gar keine Erbschaftssteuer
anfällt wenn eine Villa im Wert von
mehreren Millionen Euro vererbt wird
dann muss dafür Erbschaftssteuer gezahlt
werden und das ist auch richtig und
wichtig so
dass sie jetzt in der Debatte oder in
dem Antrag auch fordern ist eben die
regionale Anpassung der freibeträger das
hat mich ja immer auch sehr interessiert
muss ich schon wissen darüber schmunzeln
denn diese Forderung kam mir aus Bayern
kam von Markus Söder das geerbte Haus am
Starnberger See ist natürlich stärker im
Wert gestiegen als beispielsweise ein
Haus in der uk-markt aber wieso für ein
Haus der ein höherer Freibetrag gelten
soll wie er für einen ebenso wertvolles
Haus in Hessen in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
und dann Brandenburg das erschließt sich
mir überhaupt nicht das ist am Ende
wedermaßen noch Mitte das ist am Ende
wieder bayerische Klientelpolitik
ich rate den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
folgendes bleiben Sie cool be Fakt
fassen Sie sich in Ruhe mit den Fakten
und stellen sie am Ende fest dass sich
für sie in meinen meisten Fällen gar
nichts ändert die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen rate ich lehnen Sie diesen
Antrag ab vielen Dank
soweit Lennart Öl
SPD-Fraktion einer der sich hier nicht
am Kult zu Wort melden wird aber wir
Twitter um 11 Uhr persönlich seine
Position noch mal reingegeben hat
Bundeswehr transminister Christian
Lindner den wir auch gerade im Bild
gesehen haben bei persönlichen
Freibeträgen der erbschafts- und
Schenkungssteuer besteht nach meiner
Überzeugung Handlungsbedarf als reine
ländersteuer von der der Bund nicht
profitiert sollte eine Initiative für
die Anhebung jedoch vorzugsweise aus dem
Kreis der Länder ergriffen werden
Christian Lindner und jetzt für die AFD
kalkscheid ein wirklich sprachlos zurück
was hier so die Kollegen der SPD
verzapfen das unglaublich dass sie wie
ihr Wirtschaftsminister von Wirtschaft
und sozialer Marktwirtschaft und
Wirtschaft und keine Ahnung haben haben
Öl und der größenordinieren reden und
ihr Beitrag hier die wunderbar gewesen
wann wollen Sie eigentlich den
volkseigenen Betrieb in Deutschland
wieder installieren setzen sich doch
gleich zu den linken hin die ja ihre
Gleichmacher Fantasien absondern
komme aber zum Antrag der CDU da muss
ich sagen CSU das ist ja auch wieder
ähnlich wie beim Tarif auf Rädern sie
bewegen sich auf ein ORF uns zu aber ich
muss leider auch sagen gut gemeint ist
da nicht unbedingt gut gemacht sie haben
die Möglichkeit beim Antrag vom Kollegen
Glaser den wir einbringen werden dass er
eben auch in seiner Rede angesprochen
und dann den ganzen Sprung zu machen
denn dann vollziehen sie hier
entsprechend die richtigen Initiativen
und so weit können wir uns zu Ihrem
Vorschlag nur enthalten aber kommen wir
noch mal zu den Dingen haben Sie
eigentlich alle die schon länger hier
sitzen ihre katastrophale Geldpolitik
vergessen Null sind Negativzins da haben
sie Menschen gezielt und es ist
eigentlich auch gut so weil wir die
geringste Eigentumsquote haben in
Immobilien getrieben ja geradezu weil
man fürs Geld nichts mehr bekommen hat
und jetzt wollen Sie so zu sagen und das
ist nur sagen Streich diese Menschen die
das getan haben übrigens kleiner
Anmerkung die Zahlen auch Steuern die
haben das aus zu versteuern im Einkommen
gemacht wenn es nicht gerade die Leute
sind die sie alle mit haben laufen
lassen weil sie Transparenzregister und
andere Dinge vergessen haben diese Leute
wollen sie jetzt doppelt bestrafen meine
Damen und Herren und das ist wirklich
sozialer Klassenkampf den sie ja machen
das ist eine Neidgesellschaft aber keine
Wohlstandsgesellschaft die wir doch
brauchen um die Zukunftsaufgaben
zusammen hier zu bewältigen meine Damen
und Herren
nehmen wir das aber mal in einem
Beispiel sie reden hier mal so
großspurig 8 Millionen ja das ist gemein
und so weiter ein Beispiel aus dem
Münchner Merkur vom November wenn Sie
also Erbe einer Immobilie in München
hier Stroh die Spitzen sie die Ohren von
8 Millionen sind dann wie gesagt ist das
schon mal erst mal wenn Sie den den
Erblasser sehen aus sozusagen versteuert
vom Einkommen jetzt kommt folgendes
dieser 8 Millionen klingt viel aber die
Wohnung von diesem Vermieter die werden
sozial vermietet was bedeutet das also
es klang hier in dem man muss ja sagen
der Kurzintervention schauen an das
heißt der wird wenn er erben will und
muss die natürlich entsprechend bieten
erhöhen oder er muss Kredite aufnehmen
und dann wird er auch die Mieten
übernehmen weiteres Beispiel für die
lernen und willigen der SPD nehmen wir
mal eine Wertsteigerung an die ist
angegeben von VDP immobilienpreisindex
von 80% seit 2010 hätte also 2010 eine
Ehegatte eine Immobilien wird
550.000 nach Abzug des Freibetrages
geerbt wäre in der Steuerklasse bei
dreieinhalbtausend gewesen ja in Ordnung
würde er das nach ihren Maßnahmen jetzt
machen und wir nehmen die 80 Prozent
Wertsteigerungen dann sind es heute
990.000 Euro und das ist auch in Ordnung
so weil die Leute in das Geld aus dem
Geld rausgegangen sind was schwach ist
er müsste aber heute
73.500 Euro zahlen bzw Kredit aufnehmen
sie treiben die Menschen die
Altersvorsorge getrieben hat aus der
Immobilie schämen sie sich meine Damen
und Herren von der Fraktion der SPD sie
sind überhaupt nicht die Partei der
kleinen Männer oder Frauen was auch
immer aber sicherlich noch ach das
wissen die Leute doch schon in Bayern
sind sie doch eine 9% Partei wenn Sie
hier dann immer Bayern zitieren
wir nicht zu wie enthalten uns bei ihrem
guten Vorschlag machen sie den ganzen
Sprung und stimmen Sie in ein paar
Wochen in unserem Vorschlag zu dann
haben mich auch die Progression mit drin
und dann sind wir glaube ich hier auf
einem guten Weg zusammen mit dem
bürgerlichen Parteien danke
[Applaus]
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
hat nun dr Sebastian Schäfer das Wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen es
ist schon erstaunlich mit welch einem
inhaltlich extrem dünnen Antrag die
Union hier versucht ein Süppchen für
Millionäre und ihre Erben zu kochen
von wegen
leberkäseetage für die Sie gerade als
CSU angeblich Politik machen wollen mit
diesem Antrag geht es wieder einmal nur
um die die im käferzelt Champagner
trinken
sie argumentieren dass aufgrund der
deutlich gestiegenen Immobilienpreise
jetzt auch die Freibeträge beim Schenken
und Erben entsprechend steigen müssen
dabei geht es lediglich darum dass wir
die Verfassungsmäßigkeit herstellen und
Immobilien nach ihrem tatsächlichen Wert
bemessen die Grundlage dafür hat ja
richtigerweise die groko gelegt die im
Jahr 2021 im Baurecht die Immobilienwert
ermittlungsverordnung entsprechend
angepasst hat jetzt geht es lediglich
darum diese Grundlage auch für die
steuerliche Bewertung zu übertragen
Freibeträge bei Schenkungen und
Erbschaften gelten ja gar nicht nur für
Immobilien wie sie das in ihrem Antrag
suggerieren wollen sondern für alle
Vermögenswerte davon würde der Erbe oder
Beschenkte einer Aktionärin die in den
letzten Jahren deutlich steigende
Kurswerte erleben konnte genauso
profitieren aber sie wollen ja in ihrem
Antrag zu tun als wer davon nur dass
sprichwörtliche kleine Häuschen der
Großmutter betroffen und sie wissen doch
ganz genau dass wir eine Immobilie die
nach dem Tod eines Elternteils von einem
Kind übernommen und bewohnt wird
überhaupt keine Erbschaftssteuer anfällt
zumindest wenn die Immobilie nicht
größer als 200 Quadratmeter ist
selbst wenn dieses Haus am Tegernsee
oder am Bodensee steht und drei
Millionen Euro wert ist fällt da kein
einziger Cent an erbschafts-
und selbst wenn die Immobilie größer ist
muss sie schon extrem wertvoll sein dass
der Freibetrag überschritten wird und
dann tatsächlich ein wenig
Erbschaftssteuer fällig wird bleiben wir
bei unserem Haus am Tegernsee oder am
Bodensee lassen wir es diesmal 250
Quadratmeter groß sein und gehen wir
jetzt von einem Wert von 4 Millionen
Euro aus Herr März würde sagen gehobene
Mittelschicht
wenn ein Kind dieses Haus erbt und es
nutzt werden 45.000 Euro Steuern fällig
also ungefähr ein Prozent des Werts und
wenn die Immobilie zur Entrichtung der
Steuer veräußert werden müsste dann kann
die Steuer sogar für bis zu zehn Jahre
gestundet werden ich bin mir sicher
diese Sorgen hätten viele Menschen gerne
die allermeisten Menschen Erben gar
nichts oder Beträge die nicht annähernd
an die Freibeträge heranreichen
Frau Connemann aus ihrer Fraktion
ist wirklich schamlos wenn sie in der
Presse davon spricht das Wohneigentum
jetzt für Erben zur Armutsfalle werden
können sie verhöhnt damit auch die
soziale Marktwirtschaft über die sie so
gerne in ihren Sonntagsreden sprechen
sie wissen auch ganz genau das sind
vielen Fällen bei Schenkungen oder
kettenschenkungen alle zehn Jahre um die
Freibeträge auszunutzen so gestaltet
wird dass gar keine steuerfällig wird
wir sehen ja gerade was bei den Notaren
los ist da geht es nur um Schenkungen im
Zweifel wird durch Nießbrauch der Preis
gedrückt und die Steuer gespart
in ihrem Antrag ist ja auch die Rede von
einer Regionalisierung der Freibeträge
ich will das mal übersetzen die
Wertentwicklung der Grundstücke in
Deutschland war im vergangenen Jahrzehnt
höchst unterschiedlich Bayern und
Baden-Württemberg sind sicherlich
Bundesländer die in großen Teilen hohe
Immobilienpreise haben aber dies
rechtfertigt doch keine höheren
Freibeträge als anderswo warum sollte
jemand in Thüringen beim Erwerb von
einem hohen Barvermögen mehr Steuern
bezahlen als jemand in Stuttgart oder
München der denselben Wert in Form einer
Immobilie zum Beispiel eines Zinshauses
erwirbt mit ihrer Politik für die
champagner-etage Spalten Sie unser Land
deshalb kann ich für diesen Antrag für
diese dünne Suppe nur Ablehnungen
Sebastian Schäfer war das für die
Bündnis grüne Fraktion weiterhin wird
debattiert über den unionsantrag bei der
Erbschaftssteuer die Freibeträge zu
erhöhen nächster Redner jetzt Maximilian
Mordhorst für die FDP-Fraktion liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen nicht vergessen
2014/2016/2018 diese Jahre haben alle
gemeinsam dass dort das
Bundesverfassungsgericht Urteile zur
Erbschaftssteuer gefällt hat diese Jahre
haben auch gemeinsam das sind all diesen
Jahren die Union regiert hat und dort
wenig bis gar nichts verändert wurde und
dass wir jetzt vor dieser
ärgerlichen Situation stehen und es hat
auch zur Folge Liebe Union dass sie ja
nicht nur Belastungen ihre
Regierungszeit an die Zukunft gegeben
haben zum Beispiel mit der
Energieabhängigkeit von Russland nein
sie haben es jetzt sogar geschafft eine
Belastung über ihre Regierungszeit
hinaus uns rüberzugeben indem sie aus
dem Bundesministerium des Innern und für
Heimat damals Horst Seehofer
Wertermittlungsverordnung entsprechend
geändert haben was dazu führt dass die
Werte für Immobilien an einigen Stellen
es steigen und dadurch eben nicht die
Sätze der Erbschaftssteuer steigen aber
einige doch Gefahr laufen höhere
Erbschaftssteuer zahlen zu müssen das
ist schon beeindruckend es würde mich
freuen wenn die Union wie es eigentlich
eine im Antrag steht mehr für
Entlastungen arbeitet und nicht nur
darüber redet anstattbelastungen in die
Zukunft zu verlagern und deswegen haben
wir vorgeschlagen vor dieser ärgerlichen
Situation die ich hier eingestehe dass
wir die Freibeträge erhöhen das wäre gut
und richtig gewesen und ich hätte mich
gefreut wenn wir das gemeinsam
hinbekommen hätten ich hoffe dass wir es
in Zukunft hinbekommen denn Wohneigentum
ist etwas Wichtiges und wichtiges wir
sehen an ganz vielen Stellen dass dort
wo Wohnungen in staatliche Hand sind und
es hat man auch schon am Anfang der oder
Jahre gesehen sie verfallen schlechter
werden und die Sanierung dann in der
Privatisierung gemacht werden und dann
10 15 Jahre wieder drüber zu sprechen
dass man es ja verstaatlichen müsste und
das alles so unsozial sein das ist nicht
unser Weg unser Weg ist nicht
distanzsteuern immer weiter zu erhöhen
unser Weg ist nicht vermögen immer
weiter zu schwächen nein wir müssen
Vermögen stärken und das bedeutet auch
dass wir privates Wohneigentum
unterstützen wir können bei dieser
Debatte und das hat mich an einigen
Stellen gestört nicht immer nur über die
Superreichen vielleicht in München oder
Campen auf Sylt sprechen sondern wir
müssen uns doch an der breiten Mitte der
Gesellschaft orientieren und natürlich
wird die Probleme haben wenn wir bei den
substanzsteuern immer weiter rangehen
das haben wir bei den Grundstein erlebt
bei der Grundsteuer erlebt das erleben
wir jetzt ein kleines bisschen bei der
Erbschaftssteuer und es ist Warnsignal
für uns alle und ich bin froh dass wir
das im Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten
haben es ist wahnsignal für uns alle
dass wir keine weiteren Substanz Steuern
einführen sollten keine Abgaben es
bedeutet für uns keine Vermögenssteuer
keine Vermögensabgabe dafür stehen wir
und das ist richtig so wir sollten
generell einmal darüber sprechen was
Substanzen eigentlich für Probleme
verursachen wir haben es bei der
Grundsteuer erlebte hatten wir viele
Debatten gerade in den Ländern wir leben
ist bei der Erbschaftssteuer und wir
hätten es bei der Vermögenssteuer erlebt
vielleicht ist der richtige Weg nicht
vermögen immer weiter zu reduzieren und
die Gruppen gegeneinander auszuspielen
sondern vielleicht ist der Weg an vielen
Stellen Vermögen zu fördern in
Deutschland wenn man sich nämlich
anschaut die großen Aufgaben die wir
haben die werden zu einem großen Teil
private Investitionen erfordern das wird
der Staat nicht alleine machen können
und wir haben kaum ein fähigen
Kapitalmarkt zumindest im
internationalen Vergleich was unsere
Wirtschaftskraft angeht bedeutet für uns
wir müssen den Kapitalmarkt Stärken
deswegen bringen wir das
zukunftsfinanzierungsgesetz auf den Weg
wir müssen private Investitionen
unterstützen die nicht nur von
Superreichen kommen müssen sondern es
muss auch attraktiv sein für die Mitte
der Gesellschaft für den Mittelstand und
die Mittelschicht zu investieren und
sich daraus etwas zu machen das ist eine
wichtige eine wichtige Maßgabe die wir
haben und deswegen freue ich mich wenn
wir an breiter Stelle unterstützen die
Menschen die Vermögen schaffen wollen
die sich etwas aufbauen wollen die auch
sich etwas machen wollen egal ob sie
erben sind oder nicht nur an den einigen
wenigen profitieren die hier immer als
Beispiele genannt werden das ist nicht
die große und breite Mitte der
Gesellschaft wir stehen für diese große
und breite Mitte der Gesellschaft und
werden deswegen auch für ein
angemessenes und faires Steuersystem
sorgen
das ist der Plan und bleibt das Ziel und
ausgesprochen von Maximilian Mordhorst
Mitglied im Finanzausschuss FDP-Fraktion
weiterhin noch mal für die Antragende
Fraktion Fritzlar von der wir uns
Fraktion Finanzamt Ausschuss ebenfalls
Mitglied die Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren lieber Max mortos
frage mich jetzt gerade ob sie den
Antrag nun zustimmen würden das haben
sie nicht gesagt also die Argumentation
war schlüssig von dafür bedanke ich mich
für die klaren Worte und von daher
stimmen Sie die vielleicht entsprechend
ab als Redner der ziemlich am Ende der
Tagesordnung ansteht hat man ja den
Vorteil dass man sich das vorher schon
mal alles anhören durfte und ich finde
das schon spannend wie da die
Argumentationslinien laufen ich muss ihn
ganz ehrlich sagen von FDP SPD und grün
sie kommen ja so ein bisschen vor ich
kenne das von zu Hause wenn ich meine
Söhne ertappe dass sie irgendwas gemacht
haben was ich nicht sehen sollte dann
reagieren die ähnlich wie sie mich
völlig hektisch planlos und aufgeregt
und das denn sie haben wo haben sie das
denn gemacht sie haben versucht oder
haben es ja sogar gemacht morgen soll es
ja beschlossen werden im
Jahressteuergesetz untergebracht dass
wir mehrere hundert Seiten geht dort
haben sie das mal hinten so ganz kleinen
Reich reingeschrieben damit das möglich
nicht gesehen wird aber damit haben Sie
nicht mit uns gerechnet als Opposition
wir sehen sowas nämlich
weil wir eine aufmerksame Opposition
sind meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
sie ja schon wieder die Aufregung ich
finde das gut und es sind natürlich
verschiedene Gründe die sie so aufgeregt
machen zum einen die FDP der Kollege
Bremen hat es ja schon zitiert heute vor
vier Tagen am Montag hat Bundesminister
Lindner gesagt ich das so schön das muss
man noch mal zitieren fürchtet euch
nicht mit dieser Koalition und diesem
Bundesfinanzminister wird es keine
Steuererhöhung geben nun machen wir mal
den Faktencheck wie das so schön
neudeutsch heißt wir reden ja nicht nur
über die Steuererhöhung jetzt über die
Erbschaftssteuer das erste Steuergesetz
dieser Ampelkoalition war eine Erhöhung
der Steuern bei den Landwirten als die
portionierungssätze geändert worden sind
morgen im Jahre Steuergesetz beschließen
wir die nächste Steuererhöhung die
sogenannte übergewinn-besteuer die
Steuer die bei ihnen
energiekrisenbeitrag heißt aber
letztendlich machen Sie die nächste
Steuererhöhung wenn Sie das auf die
Europa schieben wollen Herr
Bundesfinanzminister dann frage ich mich
wieso sie dennoch am Montag so eine
Aussage treffen konnten weil sie ja
wussten dass sie auch sagen gar nicht
richtig sein können weil sie die Steuern
erhöhen auch ist egal warum sie sie
erhöht haben sie erhöhen permanent hier
steuern und stehen gegen ihr
Wahlversprechen und gegen ihre klaren
Aussagen und das werden wir immer wieder
anmerken
und man hat ja die Chance ein paar Dinge
richtig zu rücken richtig ist dass es
die Immobilienwerte
vermittlungsverordnung gibt die auch
übertragen werden sollte das war immer
so angelegt auf die Bewertung aber
richtig ist auch dass die entscheidenden
Parameter und das sind die Liegenschaft
Zinsen völlig frei durch das
Bundesfinanzministerium gewählt worden
sind und die sind erheblich gesenkt
worden und wenn man sich mit
Kapitalisierung auskennt führt die
Senkung von über 30% des Liegenschaft
dazu dass die Immobilienwerte um 30%
steigen das wäre nicht nötig gewesen das
hat dieses Bundesfinanzministerium
gemacht und dadurch wird es auch zu
hohen Werten kommen
und schließlich ist es es ist mehrfach
angesprochen worden glaube ich auch eine
reine Logik dass wenn der Wert steigt
das wäre nicht ganz zu vermeiden gewesen
das gebe ich auch zu dass man dann den
Freibetrag anheben muss damit man zum
gleichen steuerlichen Erwerb kommen muss
ansonsten ist es eine Steuererhöhung
denn Steuererhöhung ist nicht nur Tarif
sondern auch Erhöhung der
Bemessungsgrundlage meine Damen und
Herren
und es ist auch angesprochen worden wann
zuletzt die Freibeträge angepasst worden
sind es war mit der
Erbschaftssteuerreform zum
1.1.2019 und damals sind die Werte
gestiegen von 300 7000 auf 500.000 € bzw
bei den Kindern von 250.000 auf 400.000
€. und wer war damals
bundesfinanzminister Peer Steinbrück das
will ich nur mal erwähnen die SPD und in
die Gesetzesbegründung hat damals
verschreienberg reingeschrieben weil er
schon der Meinung war wenn Werte steigen
müssen auch die Freibeträge steigen ich
zitiere aus der Gesetzesbegründung die
Freistellung des Familien
gebrauchsvermögen orientiert sich am
Wert eines durchschnittlichen ein
Familienhauses und was damals richtig
war als heute auch richtig und von daher
müssen die Freibeträge hoch und darum
hatte Friedrich Merz völlig recht als er
dies vor der Wahl geäußert hat
und außerdem möchte ich mal sagen das
ist kein Geschenk des Gesetzgebers wenn
wir Freibeträge erhöhen sie erwähnen
hier alle
bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteilen leider
haben sie das aus dem vom 22 juni 1995
gegessen und ich darf den Leitsatz
wärmer zitieren der Spielraum für den
steuerlichen Zugriff auf den Erwerb von
todeswegen findet seine Grenze dort wo
die Steuerpflicht den Erwerber übermäßig
belastet und die ihm zugewandten
Vermögenswerte grundlegenden
beeinträchtigt auch diesen
Verfassungsgrundsatz müssen wir
berücksichtigen der zu Erhöhung der
Freibeträge zwingend führen müsste
also nochmal auf den Punkt gebracht wer
die Bewertung erhöht muss auch meines
Erachtens die Freibeträge erhöhen von
daher ist es völlig unverständlich dass
sie das nicht machen und die Folgen
sehen sie ja das ganze ist zurzeit ein
Konjunkturprogramm für Notare in unseren
Kanzleien der Steuerberater und
Wirtschaftsprüfer bei den Anwälten
häufen sich jetzt die Fragen weil die
Menschen nervös werden weil sie Sorge
haben zu übertragen da kommen sie immer
mit ihrem Familienheim den Park kann ich
ja sogar den paragraph 13 Absatz 1,4 a
bis c und das ist nicht einfach dass sie
so ein Familienheim so übertragen können
Sie müssen es mindestens 10 Jahre nach
nutzen weil Kindern ist es auch bei
Schenkung nicht zulässig nur noch beim
Erwerb von Todes Volk und die
Lebenswirklichkeit ist doch heute so
selbst wenn sie es schaffen unmittelbar
in das Elternhaus zu ziehen was er allen
zu wünschen ist kann es auch sein dass
sie innerhalb der zehn Jahren beruflich
von Ort in den Ort B ziehen müssen und
dann fällt die komplette
Erbschaftssteuer rückwirkend an das ist
länger im System da sollten wir mal
gemeinsam darüber nachdenken ob wir da
wenigsten pro rather Betrachtung
hinbekommen denn so funktioniert das
nämlich nicht wie sie sich das so
einfach mal letztendlich vorstellen von
daher gibt es viel zu tun und ich gucke
noch mal in die reine FDP mein guter
Kollege aus dem niedersächsischen
Landtag Christian der hat ja gesagt das
geht alles schnell und unbürokratisch da
hat er völlig recht morgen steht das
Jahressteuergesetz an entweder nehmen
Sie die Bewertungsfragen daraus oder
erhöhen die Freibeträge dass wir schnell
und unbürokratisch ganz im Sinne der
Familien in Deutschland ganz im Sinne
der Vermögenden in Deutschland die nur
ein Familienheim übertragen worden wir
haben hier nicht diskutiert über die
gesamte Erbschaftssteuer wie es hier
versucht wurde herzlichen Dank
soweit für die beantragenden
Unionsfraktion Fritz Künstler Mitglied
im Finanzausschuss über der vorletzte
Redner letzte Rednerin wird dann sein
Frauke Heiligenstadt für die
SPD-Fraktion danach gehen wir schon in
die Schleife für das ceta-abkommen hier
in die Ratifizierung meine Kollegin
Katharina kühn wird sie dadurch dann
begleiten ja sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lieber Herr Künstler sie sind
nicht der letzte Redner in der Debatte
gewesen ich bin die letzte Rednerin in
der Debatte und deswegen mache ich jetzt
mal den Faktencheck was sie und ihre
Kollegen hier gerade so schön an falsch
Behauptungen aufgestellt haben also
Faktencheck Nummer 1 sie behaupten wir
würden die Erbschaftssteuer erhöhen fakt
ist wir nehmen lediglich eine Anpassung
der Bewertung vor von Immobilien und das
dient das dient dem dem
Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes das ist hat
uns nämlich aufgegeben Vermögen
plötzlich gerecht zu bewerten und keine
Schlupflöcher bei der Bewertung von
Vermögen zu hinterlassen meine Damen und
Herren wir nehmen also keine
erbschaftssteuererhöhung vor sondern wir
passen das Vermögen schlicht und
ergreifend die Bewertung des Vermögens
an
Faktencheck Nummer 2 sie behaupten dass
zukünftig bereits kleine Wohnhäuser
nicht mehr ohne Erbschaftssteuer vererbt
werden können richtig ist dagegen meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren es
bleibt dabei ein Haus mit bis zu 200
Quadratmeter Wohnfläche kann indirektor
Linie bei Eigennutzung ohne
Erbschaftssteuer vererbt werden
unabhängig vom Wert der Immobilie also
auch dieser Faktencheck bei ihnen
durchgefallen
Faktencheck Faktencheck Nummer 3 sie
sprechen von unzähligen Erbfällen die
nun versteuert werden müssten fakt ist
nicht einmal mehr nicht einmal die
Hälfte unserer Bevölkerung erbt
überhaupt
Immobilienvermögen und selbst die
wenigen die Immobilienvermögen Erben
fallen nur zu einem ganz kleinen Anteil
unter die Erbschaftssteuer also auch
hier
Falschbehauptung ich sag mal
Akten chefair werden sie locker
durchgefallen da Fr man sich allerdings
warum machen sie das eigentlich nur
warum stellen Sie so viele
Falschbehauptungen auf und könnte ja
vielleicht sein dass Sie mit diesen
Falschbehauptung eigentlich von dem
guten Ergebnis zum Jahressteuergesetz
ablenken wollen sie machen sie machen
zum Beispiel mit diesem falsch
Behauptungen den Menschen Angst weil sie
nicht wollen dass wir vielleicht über
die gute Entwicklung bei der Homeoffice
pauschale reden oder das wäre die gute
Entwicklung bei der Besteuerung der
Photovoltaik reden oder dass wir nicht
über die Erhöhung der Arbeitnehmer das
Arbeitnehmer Pauschbetrages reden oder
vielleicht auch über die erhöhte
Abschreibungen für Wohnungsbau
Investition wir von der Ampel machen
Politik für die Menschen in diesem Land
und ohne den Bremsklotz
und ohne den Bremsklotz Union haben wir
in der Ampel in einem Jahr mehr
Sozialreformen durchgesetzt als in acht
Jahren großer Koalition meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren und sie
machen
sie machen nicht nur falsch Behauptungen
sondern sie garnieren das ganze auch
noch mit Emotionen mit Angst indem sie
suggerieren dass Omas kleines Häuschen
nicht mehr vererbt werden kann aber
eigentlich geht es Ihnen gar nicht um
die Eigennutzung dieses Gebäudes von Oma
sondern ihnen geht es um die Menschen
die diese Wohnung und Häuser
anschließend mit den geerbten Immobilien
wieder vermieten wollen und das wird
insbesondere daran deutlich dass sie in
ihrem Antrag vorschlagen eine Erhöhung
der Fehlbeträge für Ehegatten auf 825
000 €. für Kinder auf 660.000 €
vorzusehen und meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren Freibeträge das heißt
also eine Verschonung von der
Erbschaftssteuer das letzte Mal als wir
hier an diesem Pult über schon Vermögen
gesprochen haben ging es um das
Schonvermögen für Menschen die zukünftig
Bürgergeld bekommen sollen und ich finde
es
ich finde es ehrlich gesagt sehr
beschämt dass sie nur wenige Tage nach
der die unsäglichen Debatte darüber dass
für diese Menschen ein Schonvermögen von
60.000 Euro einschließlich einer
Immobilie zu hoch sei nun für Reiche
vorschlagen die Freibeträge von 400.000
Euro auf
825.000 Euro zu erhöhen ich sag nur
Klientelpolitik für Reiche Hua und und
statt
seit ihrer klientelanträge brauchen wir
eine sachliche Debatte wie wir mit der
steigenden Ungleichheit von Vermögen und
Chancen durch Erbschaften umgehen und
möglichst vielen Menschen Teilhabe
ermöglichen wenn Sie also ernsthaft
Interesse an einer sachlichen Debatte
zeigen dann können wir uns gern mit
ihren Vorschlägen auseinandersetzen
keine Zwischenfrage schon gar nicht von
der afd-fraktion aber der Antrag der
CDU-Fraktion der Antrag der CDU-Fraktion
das war heute morgen mit dem Zusatzpunkt
echter rohrkrippierer bei ihnen vielen
Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den Antrag der
Fraktion der cdu/csu auf Drucksache
4.674 mit dem Titel keine
erbschaftssteuererhöhung durch die
Hintertüren wer stimmt für diesen Antrag
die cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
die Koalitionsfraktionen und die
Fraktion DIE LINKE wer enthält sich die
afd-fraktion der Antrag ist damit
abgelehnt und damit kommen wir zum
nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt der geht es um das
Wirtschafts- und Handelsabkommen ceta
das ist nämlich seit 2017 nur teilweise
in Kraft seit 13 Jahren gibt es ja immer
wieder Verhandlungen über dieses
Abkommen zwischen der Europäischen Union
und Kanada da gab es viel Misstrauen
viel Zweifel vielleicht erinnern Sie
sich noch an die Debatte über die
chlorhühnchen die so befürchtete man nun
die deutschen Supermärkte bevölkern
würden die Idee ist ja natürlich bei
diesem Handelsabkommen die Möglichkeiten
für den Handel und für die Investitionen
zwischen EU und Kanada zu steigern ein
besseren Markt Zugang für Waren und
Dienstleistungen zu generieren und klare
Handelsregeln zu schaffen aber man hatte
eben besonders auch in Deutschland Angst
das ist mit diesem Abkommen
abgesenkte Gesundheits- und
Umweltstandards geben könnte eine
Politikerin die damals übrigens
2006 16 war das dagegen demonstriert hat
ist mittlerweile unsere Außenministerin
Annalena baerbock lief damals bei einer
der größten Demos gegen das Abkommen
ceta und ttip mit mittlerweile sind die
Grünen da anderer Meinung und zwar in
Form von
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck der
hier auch schon in dem
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
auf der Regierungsbank sitzt die Grünen
haben es geschafft das Umzug
formulieren wie sie nun esceta sehen
dass sie sagen Globalisierung kann
stattfinden wenn sie fairer und
nachhaltiger werden kann und deswegen
hat auch Robert Habeck gemeinsam mit der
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Katharina dröge in
einem Papier sich ganz deutlich für Sie
da ausgesprochen und Katharina dröge
wird nun hier auch die Debatte eröffnen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen gestern war ein
großartiger Tag wir leiten als Koalition
ein neues Kapitel in der Handelspolitik
ein eine Handelspolitik die Klimaschutz
und Nachhaltigkeit endlich in den
Mittelpunkt der Handelspolitik stellt
und nicht wie es in der Vergangenheit
passiert ist als Anhalt betrachtet
deshalb war es so wichtig dass das
Bundeskabinett gestern entschieden hat
aus dem
energievertrag auszusteigen das ist ein
historischer Schritt Deutschland kündigt
den klimaschädlichsten Handelsvertrag ab
die nicht Europäische Union jeweils
abgeschlossen hat es war völlig absolut
das deutsche Unternehmen die Niederlande
vor einem internationalen Schiedsgericht
verklagen konnten weil die Niederlande
den Kohleausstieg beschlossen haben es
ist völlig absurd gewesen das Warten
Fall vor einem internationalen
Schiedsgericht gegen den deutschen
Atomausstieg klagen konnte damit in
Zukunft Schluss
wir haben uns in der Koalition auf eine
umfassende Neuausrichtung der
Handelspolitik geeinigt und in Richtung
der CDU weil ich mir ungefähr vorstellen
kann was Frau Klöckner die gleich nach
mir spricht sagen wird das geht wenn man
sich zuhört das geht wenn man die
Argumente voneinander ernst nimmt und
nicht Spur mit dem Kopf durch die Wand
will wie die Union das in den letzten
Jahren praktiziert hat sie haben in der
Handelspolitik in den letzten Jahren
nämlich einfach gar nichts hingekriegt
mit der Ampel geht es jetzt voran wir
haben uns darauf verständigt auf
europäischer Ebene zuzustimmen als die
Kommission den Vorschlag gemacht hat das
künftig Klimaschutz und Nachhaltigkeit
mit einklagbaren Standards versehen
werden das ist etwas was vor einigen
Jahren nur die Grünen und die
Umweltbewegung in Deutschland gefordert
haben jetzt wird das gemeinsame
europäische Realität und dass man solche
Handelsabkommen vereinbaren kann das hat
die europäische un vor kurzem mit
Neuseeland gezeigt und es ist richtig
und es ist gut dass die Kommission das
neuseeländische Abkommen zum
Goldstandard ihre Handelspolitik erklärt
hat wir haben
auf der sagt mit dem alten System der
Schiedsgerichte ist Schluss deswegen
haben wir uns darauf verständigt
Investitionsschutzabkommen Zukunft nur
noch dann ratifizieren zu wollen wenn
sie sich auf die beiden Paragraphen
konzentrieren die wirklich relevant sind
für Unternehmen nämlich direkte
Enteignung und Diskriminierung aufgrund
der Tatsache dass man ein ausländisches
Unternehmen ist mit den anderen beiden
Paragraphen die für viele klagen die
missbräulich nicht angewendet wurden die
Grundlage waren ist in Zukunft aufgrund
unserer Handel
und ja wir zeigen auch bei Sita was geht
wenn man sich einig ist was geht wenn
man einander zuhört wir haben es
geschafft gemeinsam mit der Europäischen
Kommission gemeinsam mit den
Mitgliedstaaten in der EU und gemeinsam
mit Kanada einen Vorschlag zu machen der
genau diese beiden missbrauchsanfälligen
und gefährlichsten Standards der
investitionsschutzverträge zu
reformieren einzuschränken klar zu
machen was in Zukunft alles nicht
gemeint ist und damit werden
missbräuchliche Klagen gegen Klimaschutz
und gegen Nachhaltigkeit in Zukunft so
Geschichte sein
und ein letzter Punkt weil ich ja auch
höre aus der Union dass sie von einem
neuen ttip Träumen ich frage mich immer
wieder ob sie eigentlich eine Politik
ohne jeglichen Bezug zu Realität machen
weil wo sind denn die USA über die sie
da reden wo sind denn die USA die bereit
wären ein solches Abkommen mit uns zu
verhandeln die existieren heute nicht
und die haben in der Vergangenheit auch
nicht existiert ttip ist gescheitert
schon unter Obama nicht aufgrund der
europäischen Umweltschutzbewegung ich
hätte mich gefreut wenn ich mich hier
hätte hinstellen können und sagen können
das war unser Erfolg tatsächlich war es
das Ergebnis von nicht überein zu
bringen den Interessen ökonomischer Art
zwischen der EU auf der einen Seite und
den USA auf der anderen Seite die
existieren heute in noch größere Maße
deswegen ist Teil einer realistischen
Handelspolitik dass man sich anschaut
was geht dass man nicht träumt von
gigantischen monsterverträgen die sich
gegenseitig blockieren und die zu Recht
von den Menschen in Frage gestellt
werden sondern dass man sagt lasst uns
kleinere Regeln finden lasst uns da
vorangehen wo es pragmatisch auch
sinnvoll ist lasst uns Gremien nutzen
wie den Trans Atlantic technology
Council wo wir eh schon miteinander
überstanden hat sprechen da kann man
realistisch Vorankommen lasst uns über
umweltschutzgüter sprechen lasst uns mal
ernst machen damit dass die EU und die
USA ein großer gemeinsamer
Wirtschaftsraum für Nachhaltigkeit sind
so wie es die amerikanische Regierung
auch verkündet hat da liegen Chancen der
immer in der Vergangenheit hängen bleibt
der kann die Zukunft nicht gestalten und
das ist vielleicht eine Lehre für Sie
als Union
Katharina dröge hat hier die Debatte
eröffnet und das seta-abkommen in der
jetzigen Form verteidigten momentan ist
es in der EU ja nur teilweise in Kraft
erst alle EU-Staaten müssen das Abkommen
ratifiziert haben bis es komplett in
Kraft tritt Julia Klöckner spricht jetzt
Herr Bundesminister
ister unsere Wirtschaft muss
unabhängiger werden von
autarkin der Diversität Diversifizierung
also eine breitere Aufstellung will
unabhängiger werden will der muss
natürlich
für Freihandel sein Freihandel mit
möglichst vielen strategischen Partnern
und Freunden in der Welt alleine schon
für die angestrebte Transformation für
die sogenannte Energiewende sind wir auf
wichtige Rohstoffe von anderen
Kontinenten angewiesen die Nickel wie
Kupfer oder auch Lithium aber viel zu
oft wird Freihandel viel zu oft in der
öffentlichen Debatte als etwas Negatives
dargestellt und angeheizt von den Grünen
sie haben in der vergangenen
Legislaturperiode alle
Globalisierungskritiker auf die Bäume
getrieben und jetzt erzählen sie das
Märchen der interpretationserklärung
dass sie das ruderum gerissen hätten
weil die die auf den Bäumen sind jetzt
endlich wieder runterkommen müssen das
ist ihr Problem
aber kein anderes außer europäisches
Land steht uns in allen grundlegenden
Werten und der inneren Ordnung näher als